project Veritas just put out the video
we were talking about a little bit
yesterday that when they went to
confront this Pfizer director asking
about comments he made
discussing mutating the covid virus
profit The Man became irate loses it
totally starts accusing Veritas of doing
illegal things then physically attacks
the Veritas crew stealing the the iPad
and like falling to the ground chaos
ensues the store owner locks James
O'Keefe in the building this guy's
screaming calling the police apparently
after James O'Keefe leaves the dude is
waving his arms in front of vehicles and
cars screaming yelling calling the cops
yeah this is crazy this is this is a
crazy story the guy goes out and says
I'm not really I don't really work there
Mom I'm a consultant and I was just
lying to impress somebody but the way he
freaks out and loses his mind
says something because you know maybe
he's telling the truth maybe he was
lying maybe he was just trying to
impress a date that's fine James O'Keefe
didn't come out and say they're
definitively doing gain of function
research he said a director at Pfizer
said these things why tell us about it
and the dude goes off now that story I
really want to talk about because I
think I think it matters
what these big Pharma companies are
doing
but yo we got such crazy news today
Atlanta
antifa's going nuts so the government is
activating a thousand National Guard wow
who'da thought Antonov Zone has grown
out of control and there's I don't know
terrorism happening they're charging
these people with terrorism so it's not
even riots anymore we're at that level
then we got this the the FDA has come
out and YouTube keep your pants on
the FDA we have the story we have the
fact check newsguard certified
is warning about a connection between
strokes and taking the flu shot and the
coveted shot if you get them within a
certain amount of time it increases your
risk of stroke that's actually being
reported right now then the U.S
ascending tanks the German foreign
minister says we are at war with Russia
and it's just like wow a lot of this
news happening like within the past hour
it's one heck of a Thursday my friends
before we get started head over to
timcast.com become a member and support
our work directly as a member of
timcast.com you are supporting not only
our work doing shows like this but our
cultural Endeavors and you'll get access
to exclusive members only shows
uncensored we will have one of those
shows for you tonight at about 11 pm so
if you want to check it out it is uh
it's always good fun not so family
friendly and of course I mentioned in a
million times we got this Cafe that
we're building and we have a plan for
tons of physical location activities to
bring people together to share ideas so
that we can actually have a bigger
impact on the culture you'll also notice
over at timcast.com there is a link up
top a banner ad that says Tim cast IRL
with lucrid Caskey Alex Jones Alex Stein
Blair White Michael Mouse Austin Texas
April 14th live at the Vulcan theater if
you want to watch Tim cast IRL the show
as we normally do it on a Friday but
live in the audience with drinks and I'm
I'm really trying to get a bunch of
burgers to give out to everybody
I'm hoping we can get a few hundred
Burgers so that when you enter I don't
know if they'll let us do it but I'm
trying to because I gotta uh I've got a
plan for this I know this dude who makes
a bunch of burgers down in Austin it'll
be really cool that you get a free
burger or two with your with your seat
or whatever if you really want it so I'm
really excited for this event check that
out but don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends joining us
tonight to talk about this and so much
more is Joe Kent okay Tim thanks for
having me on absolutely welcome yeah
welcome back uh who are you what are you
doing so I spent about 20 plus years uh
in the military it was a Green Beret I
retired from that and then I kind of got
into politics I ran last cycle in 2022
won my primary won the Republican
nomination and then came up a little bit
short in the general and that was so
much fun I decided that I'm gonna do it
all over again so we just didn't just
announced about two weeks ago that we're
back in the fight for 24 for Washington
so I mean you're getting started early
is that that's really right that's early
we started early last time I mean look
unfortunately these things take a lot of
money and so you need time to uh to
build up that war chest especially if
you're taking out an incumbent and then
also we just wanted to keep the moment
I'm going because a lot of people are
unhappy with the the results and I I'm
gonna I don't answer this but I I really
I'm curious what would happen to your
District if Eastern Oregon actually ends
up seceding like do you have to move to
Idaho but we'll talk about that we'll
talk about that so thanks for hanging
out we also got Phil Labonte hanging out
hello everybody I am Phil Avanti Phil
from uh All That Remains Phil that
remains on Twitter uh yeah happy to be
here we're in a collared shirt today
trying to let you know the thing is I
know a lot of people watch this and like
Tim's Tim's let me come in I want to do
do the band proud you know I don't want
to embarrass my bandmates so right on
Hannah Claire bermill is hanging out
yeah I'm here I'm Hannah Brimley I'm a
writer for timcast.com for some reason
they switched seats I don't know
whatever uh I just want everyone to
notice what's not behind Phil right now
I don't have control over these things
we took the Biden down the creepy Biden
was scaring children he's creepy he's a
creepy you see the painting yeah so we
were like we should we should get rid of
that it was the right move it was
definitely not just American flag it
makes us feel good you know perfect now
he's just kind of lurking below the
table though I'm not sure if that's any
better you can wear Secrets Joe come on
over there and get him give me a joke we
just want no he's always with us that's
we got surge pressing the buttons yo
what's up guys astros.com let's do this
right on all right let's jump into this
first story check out this tweet we got
this tweet from Benny Johnson he posted
the video from Project Veritas I suppose
I could have just pulled it up from
Veritas but Benny Johnson had a really
great hashtag attached to it lied
suddenly and we all thought that was
pretty good so shout out to Benny and uh
this is the video I'll play just a
little bit 10 minutes long I'm not gonna
play the whole thing for you but we'll
play a little bit of this so you can see
what happens
you work for Pfizer my question for you
is why is Pfizer want to hide from the
public the fact that they're mutating
the covet viruses I'm literally a liar I
was trying to impress a person on a date
don't touch me well this is not why the
way don't tell anybody who's just
working in a company
you really did please
can you please unlock your door
please unlock don't let them leave
please please unlock the door then look
at your tax James look at this
please unlock please unlock it this is
crazy please unlock
the door he says you can't just record
people like that actually you can
this is the best video in ages yo this
video is crazy that was the highlight
reel and we talked about it a little bit
yesterday so for those that don't know
the context James O'Keefe's project
Veritas was undercover filming a guy
who's listed as the direct a Pfizer
director of strategic research or
something like that and he's saying that
they're exploring mutating kovid to sort
of preempt it so they can make more
vaccines make more money after vaccines
he says don't tell anybody they even
have a clip in this where he's like
you're not recording me are you why you
keep talking about this you shouldn't
don't be don't be recording me or
whatever
so that's the context here now I think
James has been particularly forthcoming
in breaking down what this story is
you'll notice the first thing that James
shows in it is the guy saying I am a
liar I was trying to impress someone on
a date not true he says I'm not I'm not
a doctor he says I'm just a consultant
Veritas put that right in the first 15
seconds they want you to understand that
of course what you're going to hear from
the fact Checkers and I'll pull this up
is they're trying to make it seem like
Veritas came out and asserted that
Pfizer was doing this right no no what
Veritas came out and said was hey we got
this guy on camera who is listed as a
director at Pfizer saying they're
they're looking into doing this can we
get some answers as to what why he's
talking about that hey maybe maybe he is
just trying to impress some guy in a
date I would be surprised I talked about
it the other day I think that happens
people are you know there's hey let me
tell you about the corporate malfeasance
I'm involved in yeah for some reason
they think it'll attract a mate the
Third first that's why it's The Thirst
but yo um man like we got a bunch of
crazy news but when I actually saw the
video of the dude physically attacking
the Veritas crew and then take a look at
this at the end James leaves let me play
the like the last minute check this out
come on guys where's the where's the car
where's the vehicle keep walking come on
let me let me say so he's listening but
let me also I also want to point out
they locked the Veritas crew in the
restaurant this is the weird thing James
walks in all calmly walks up to this
this guy and he's like can you can you
answer why you said these things the
dude goes to the the store owner store
owner takes his side immediately and
James is like this calm dude wearing a
suit being like I'm just a journalist
asking questions here's what gets crazy
she says you need to leave and he goes
okay we're leaving
then this guy uh Walker says no no don't
let them leave don't leave and James is
like ma'am he doesn't want us to leave
should should we is it okay if we stay
and ask him a few questions then the
lady apparently or someone at the
restaurant goes and locks them in
event and James is like can you please
unlock the door and let me leave it's
the craziest story and then so here's
where we're at now James is leaving
check this out witness one of the most
remarkable interactions ever do we have
the iPad so we're getting into the
vehicle now where's our car
so it says Walker desperately tried to
stop a car he believed was crewed by
Veritas
and that car is like what is going on
but but this by this point Jameson
production had already left the
restaurant
you're crazy
[Music]
he's charging the guy charging charging
charging you can't make it a list at
this point
okay if he was here you'd arrest that
guy
if James O'Keefe was still there they
would have arrested Walker here's what I
got to say about this what we should we
should talk about
the ending there I think is the most
revealing that he tried to stop a random
car jumping up and down in the street
yeah what must be going through this
guy's mind that he would have such
what's the unhinged reaction like Yo
dude lost it I'm kind of wondering you
know he works he's saying like I'm lying
I swear I'm lying and I'm wondering if
he spilled the beans in a situation
where uh you spilled the beans like this
you could sink a multi-billion dollar
company you're going to cause a lot of
problems his reaction is only making it
worse yeah absolutely and like what's in
his contract that they can bring against
him now like what penalties oh bro the
advisor I can't imagine NDA violation
easy yeah at least I imagine that that
you know being in that situation could
end his career I mean who's going to
want to hire the guy well I mean to be
honest
If he if his reaction to James O'Keefe
was like look man they're really doing
it and I don't know what I'm supposed to
do and it freaks me out that's why I was
talking about it I got a job with James
okay
he could have been one of those
whistleblowers against one of those
GoFundMe instead he loses his mind
attacks them now nobody no no not
nobody's anywhere but I don't know what
do you think is this just a guy who was
lying because he wanted some dude to
like him I I think the big thing is we
just need the government and Pfizer to
just be honest with us I mean I feel
like this whole thing I feel like this
whole interaction was kind of like a
microcosm of covid since 2020 like if
somebody said something and then someone
else James O'Keefe came and said hey can
I get some more information on that and
then the regime and they lock him in and
they freak out you can't ask that
question you're you're the liar the
gaslighting starts you're the one that's
in the wrong then we all get locked
inside together I mean this has been the
reaction since kovitz started anytime a
reasonable person says hey can we get a
little bit more information on this this
is this is interesting that there was
the Wuhan Institute of Urology right
there do you think maybe it came from
that lab boom you're new automatically
you say hey I don't want to you know
have to take this vaccine I don't want
to have to lock my community down and
then boom they are all over you just
like this the exact same reaction that
gentleman had stuff with wuhen I that's
the this the thing that really bothers
me the most is that is the most
obvious assumption that people are going
to make now I don't know if it's true or
not right whether it came from the the
lab or not personally it seems likely to
me but at the same time it also seems
the most obvious thing that people are
going to assume right you know so to to
New People's you know Twitter pages or
or social media accounts or whatever
for saying something that is
for an uninformed person the person
that's ignorant about
how viruses work and stuff making that
kind of conclusion saying oh well that
that seems it to me and then just being
like well you lose all of your your
social social media privileges just
because you thought of something that
seemed like an obvious idea the lab leak
Theory stuff was weird early on during
the pandemic we we talked about it I
talked about it there was no issue on
YouTube then all of a sudden for like a
few months there was if you claimed it
was a lab leak all of a sudden it was
like now you're getting banned yeah then
all of a sudden it was gone again and
then Jon Stewart came out and he said
come on guys like you think the BET
coronavirus emerged from a wet market
across the street from the Wuhan
coronavirus Research Center yeah come on
and then Colbert actually argued with
him and I'm like at that point
everyone's kind of leaning the direction
and I think it's fair to say
it's
there's there's no Direct
proof I I think it's fair to say common
sense or a reasonable assumption is yo
come on yeah but do we have like I'll
put it this way what we do have is early
on the pandemic there were researchers
at the University of Beijing who put out
a report or some research paper saying
that people have been bitten by bats and
peed on by bats
we I would like some sworn testimony on
that but hey look you're dealing with
communist China good luck getting it
right so I think it is a reasonable
assumption that it's the case but uh you
know what
I I don't know I'm not an expert I defer
to uh directors at Pfizer right let's
see what they have to say we'll work on
these things and tell their dates that
it most likely came from a lab because
they were doing gain of function
research yeah I
think when he goes like all men I lied
the bigger the story the bigger the LIE
yeah for him to come out I lied I lied
it's like okay now I don't think you did
right you know if if he came out like
there's so many things he could have
done
he could have come out and been and
started just he could have told James
I've been working with the CEO directly
and then you started hammering out the
lies had totally discredited himself
instead he goes the route of physically
attacking screaming jumping in front of
cars yelling I'm a liar I'm a liar
please believe me it's like really bad
bro if you're a liar I'm not going to
believe you yeah you know I mean I'm
gonna so I'll tell you what I think I
don't think he was lying to impress a
date I think he was trying to impress a
date
there's there's a part of this video I
think it's this video where right here
check this out check this out look at
this this part right here let me play
this part not want the public to know
that you guys are doing directed
evolution
I know it's freaking me out give me
these like flashbacks about like same
organization of like those conservative
people who like randomly go into
organizations and then like the friend
people in the workings organizations and
then report them which happens to people
that fighter so it's like freaks me out
when people start asking a lot of
questions
because um I just want to know the
answer
oh my God
and he was oh man yep that's so crazy
what's going on here oh
That's crazy dude that's hilarious so
what this reminds me of why are we back
up here yeah because I want to know the
answer like Chris Hanson yeah so he
thought it but then he still wanted to
continue impressing his day and so the
next day when James O'Keefe comes in
he's just like oh man yeah we talked
about this before you were saying like
at what point do they start being
suspicious right that like if you keep
asking specifically about this job that
you're not supposed to talk about at
what point are they like maybe this
something's going on but I guess this is
this this person is so I don't know
unhinged maybe a little bit emotionally
his wife is why I think he's telling the
truth he actually gets to the point
where he expresses why are you asking me
this it kind of makes me feel like I'm
being recorded
yeah like he's starting to realize hey
wait a minute what I'm saying could be a
problem I think people stayed in though
third day I think he said third day
through the video man I mean I gotta say
I I do feel bad
because
these people are on dates
They're laughing they're enjoying
themselves this guy goes on some dating
app meets some guy he really likes and
then you know he's like they're out for
pizza they got this nice Pizza there
could you imagine like sitting down
you're chilling not trying to think
about work the dude you're actually with
is about to destroy your life yeah and
are you secretly recording you I do feel
bad for him it is also at the same time
hilarious I can't help it well no his
reaction going crazy is is hilarious but
I'm just like
man I think his brain broke when he
realized yeah he's totally panicking
yeah look when you get a Twitter
employee being like yeah we ban people
then the information gets released by
Veritas it's like well what's the worst
that's going to happen your liberal
friends are gonna be like good for you
screw those Nazis but what happens if
you come out and you're like all those
evil things have been accused of that
you don't believe are happening I admit
it to people in private and now
everybody knows I said it and that I you
know either I'm lying or we're doing it
so now now what are you gonna do yeah he
knows he's basically going to validate
the argument of the the other side that
they've already said is completely and
totally evil so where does that leave
him I think that's probably wise I bet
the media comes out now and says
unmentally unhinged man confronted by
veritas
story completely discredited you think
they're gonna throw him under the bus oh
yeah
it's true if he has
he has they're going to use it for their
protection check out the story from
Newsweek fact check does project Veritas
video show Pfizer is mutating covet hold
on there a little minute Newsweek why
are you fact checking a claim that's not
been made
this is the interesting about how the
media manipulates public perception
project Veritas released a story that
says Pfizer director says thing they did
not say thing was happening they said
hey look we filmed a guy who said
they're exploring mutating kovid that he
thinks the virus came from the lab Etc
or or intimated that it did
so the media does is does project
Veritas video show Pfizer is mutating
coven
when no one made that claim right now
they can come out and say false it
doesn't here's the crazy thing about it
though
we'll jump straight uh straight down to
the bottom actually it leans slightly
towards true it says unverified so it's
not misleading it's not false and it's
not satire it's just unverified which
puts their needle leaning towards true
okay that's kind of crazy because James
did not say that they that Pfizer as a
company was doing this thing
now a bunch of people that complain
about the fact check because the fact
check does just needlessly disparage
project Veritas and falsely frame the
question at hand but when even Newsweek
anything Newsweek isn't the worst but
when even they try to falsely frame this
and still end up with oh can you say
it's not true yeah it's kind of
interesting where we're at these days
yeah I don't know and they're just
trying to throw so much like white noise
I think at it to avoid the obvious
question I mean everything that guy says
is very compelling especially when you
verify his CV like this guy actually is
working on these things and the obvious
question is what is he talking about but
then they have to throw this well you
know did he did they really say they
were doing gain a function just debunked
in that yeah I guess the crazy thing is
the media is not even they're completely
ignoring it yeah I mean I I shouldn't
say it's crazy in the context of
Newsweek trying to do a fact check yep
it's crazy that ever that this is
completely being ignored when the video
I think it got in like eight hours 10
million views probably more because I
shared it other people re-hosted it
things like that but I but I'm pretty
sure 10 million views in this video in a
day
it's wild I mean I I think that I think
the consensus here is probably that he
was not actually lying that he is
telling the truth because even if you're
even if you were thinking I'm going to
tell this person stories that are not
true to impress them why would you tell
them the stuff that the people you just
said you are afraid are coming to find
you why would you tell them the stuff
that they're looking at here that's why
I was saying like when he's in the video
being like you're not one of those
secret conservatives recording me right
it's like he's starting he's starting to
think wait a minute did I just spill the
beans on this one yeah but ultimately I
guess here's my question we'll make a
political like what do we do about it so
let's let this guy said this thing okay
he did it's a fact he said it James
O'Keefe has done his due diligence and
shown this guy is listed as having this
job so uh what do we get like other
other should the Republicans subpoena
this guy I would think so yeah they're
doing the uh the covet investing
education they're launching that what do
we get out of it do you think anything
will come of it well hopefully we get
some sunlight and we get to actually see
once and for all maybe not everything we
want to see but we get some very basic
questions asked I mean I I think this
just goes into the file of all the other
evidence we have I mean everything
that's happening right now in the
medical community died suddenly all that
the questions that people have I would
add this to that long list and that this
guy should be subpoenaed you know he
should be he should be questioned or the
folks that work for him his supervisor I
mean this just gives us a starting point
I think it's interesting that he is so
comfortable with this information that
you know first second third date he's
talking about it right like that's
unusual everyone has a first day
anecdote that they you know bring out to
like show your personality or whatever
and this is his right so that means that
he's in an environment where they're
openly talking about this comfortably
right like this can't be the only person
he can't have only told a project
Veritas person about this like who else
and that means that this is something
that they because what struck me about
the first video is him saying like oh
yeah it could be bad for America but
it's good for us and then in this video
he's like talking about himself how
could he ever trust anything like it
it's only self-centered motivation yeah
do you think
the Republican Congress is actually
going to do legitimate investigations
into all of these issues I mean it's not
just the pandemic stuff you got the
hunter Biden stuff we we talked about
this before they before they narrowly
won but we're not entirely confident I
mean we as in the people on the show
that uh Kevin McCarthy is actually going
to give us real investigations so far so
good I mean I uh I I think what the
direction they're heading right now
they're putting the right people on
those committees I mean MTG is on the
covid committee I mean how that that's
pretty awesome we've got Jim Jordan uh
Dan bishop and a couple other Fighters
that are on the the government
accountability of the modern day Church
committee
um going after the intelligence
Community that's when you have the
administrative state so we've got the
right people lined up now a big question
is what can they do they can issue
subpoenas unfortunately since the budget
got approved all these different
agencies they have their money so these
agencies can do what they just did with
Jim Jordan he issued some subpoenas and
they said the doj said we'd love to we'd
love to help however this stuff's all
under investigation so we can't help you
so Congress is a little bit Limited in
saying that hey if you guys don't show
up and participate we are going to
withhold some of your funding that's not
going to be available until next year
but I think right now the direction
things are heading I think we will start
getting some some answers at least my
biggest fear is is not about answers is
it's that we'll get some kind of answers
but there will be nothing that's done
like we could find out terrible things
that Pfizer is doing awful things but
because the executive branch is is
Democrat and it's Joe Biden I don't I
don't see him actually making a move but
this is what this is exactly why I asked
it James O'Keefe does this sting
operation gets a pretty damning quote
from someone high up at Pfizer be it a
consultant or otherwise maybe he's lying
sure this warrants in my opinion
investigation absolutely
but it's not even about the executive
branch it's like
so we have this this panel of course
with people like Marjorie Taylor green
are they going to issue the subpoenas
are they actually going to get documents
are they actually going to make people
come in and testify even beyond the
executive branch but I think your
Point's better that we can maybe assume
Marjorie Taylor Green's definitely do
something yeah but then what the doj
does nothing yeah the only thing
Congress has the is the sergeant-at-arms
other than that it's like they can't
they can't do anything to to make
anything happen unless the exact unless
you are evil like Chef yeah well I mean
even to be fair he didn't even get to
another good thing is that we got shift
kicked off the Intel committee Chief Dan
swallow well that dude is pretty epic
evil man yeah absolutely held
accountable I mean he he released
private phone records of a city member
of Congress Devan Nunes and he released
the private phone records of a U.S a
private U.S citizen yeah John Solomon
and a journalist yeah
he he said in February of 2018 that they
had evidence Trump colluded with Russia
but it just wasn't publicly available
this guy was lying yeah the whole time
that's scary that's like one of the
number one ways you can abuse your
security clearance I mean I had a
security clearance the entire time I was
in the military I worked in the CIA for
a little bit for but for him to lie and
say I have this access to classified
information it's really bad I can't tell
you what it is you just have to trust me
we need to start ruining people's lives
like that anybody else would be
absolutely annihilated out of the
intelligence Community can you can you
talk about your time at the CIA sure
limits like what what did you do yeah I
was a paramilitary operations officer so
case officer who is has a special
operations background who goes into this
paramilitary he's a CIA guy that gets
into gun fights there you go yeah yeah
so the core mission of the CIA is to go
out and to recruit human sources a lot
of places that we need to do that are
very dangerous places and so they'll
hire guys out of Special Operations but
so you work directly with the CIA you
weren't like a contract or anything no
yeah I was a full I was a full-on GS
employee what's what what's your general
opinion considering what we've seen with
the doj with the intelligence Community
with a lot of corruption what's your
what's your assessment oh it's rotten to
the or I mean the CIA the FBI doj like
the problem is we've had these
bureaucrats that have been running
things at the mid to senior levels the
pentagon's the same way I spent 20 years
in the military your average person who
enlists in the military or becomes an
officer in the military they you know
they wanted they're just you know like I
was they want to go serve their country
same thing in the intelligence Community
however there is this administrative
class that endures every single
Administration that we really never saw
rear its ugly head in all of our
lifetimes obviously Kennedy and all that
but really until Trump came in so I came
in in 98 under Clinton served all the
way through and like when Obama was
elected most of us I was a Green Bay at
the time you know we lean a little bit
right not all of us but we weren't happy
that Obama won but we took an oath to
support and defend the Constitution
Obama was the boss none of us questioned
it you know fast forward eight years
when Trump gets elected and that's not
who the administrative State the mid the
managerial class that's not who they
want and it was a night and day
difference like they basically said that
they were not going to adhere to Trump's
orders and they follow through that like
how did they Implement that uh the
implemented that mostly by just slow
roll I mean especially this is basically
the long story of how I got into
politics my late wife was also in the
military she was killed fighting Isis in
Syria one month after Trump gave the
order to pull our troops out because
Trump ran on hey I'm going to end these
endless Wars we need to go fight and
Destroy Isis but once we destroy Isis
we're not staying in Syria there was a
huge concerted effort there still is
within the administrative State the dod
to keep us in Syria and do like another
great regime change War because those
always work out so well and Trump wasn't
having any of it he gave the order to
pull the troops out Mattis resigns Brett
mcgurk over at State resigns and Trump's
orders the commander-in-chief the people
that the American people chose his
orders were completely and totally
disregarded and a month later my wife
was killed over there so that's and so
I've seen that time and time again and
with trump it went everywhere from like
the benign Slow Roll public resignation
all the way to everything we've seen
with Russia gate the tools of the
intelligence Community being used
against a candidate and a political
campaign at the time all the way to all
the guys in government you know I mean I
could go on for I could go on for hours
about about all that but yeah I mean I
think the Trump Administration just
really because they weren't expecting
him to come in and they weren't
expecting him to push back so hard we
really got a snapshot of what's going on
below the surface there that's something
that I think is is one of the most
valuable things about the Trump
presidency
um as much as there are people out there
that are going to go ahead and and
say that Trump was you know a foreign
agent or in bed with foreign agents and
stuff it really did show that the
bureaucracy really is the whole it's the
uni party one there's one agenda that
the government has and the whether it be
Republican or a Democrat the differences
are are marginal you know you're talking
about a two or three degree shift in
policy mostly cosmetic yeah and then you
get someone in like Trump that
regardless of what you think of him it
seems like the guy really wanted to do
the things that he said and everybody
was flipping out because when does a
politician try to do the things that
they said they're going to do like that
hasn't happened in decades or whatever
so I think that it was a really good
thing that that at the very least Trump
being in office and seeing that the
bureaucracy the the entrance bureaucracy
or the Deep State whatever you want to
call it they literally are running the
show and will do everything they can to
throw a monkey wrench and even the
presidents so yeah what do you say to
people who will just say you're you're a
Fed why should I trust you yeah I mean
that's uh I understand I get that
actually quite a bit
um yeah
I mean I tell people my background was
my job in the CIA is you know
counterterrorism but if we're going to
take down the administrative State we
need people from the inside who
understands exactly how the sausage is
made where the where the secrets are
kept and those types of things because I
think a lot of times we get when
Congress calls these intelligence
officials Department of Defense folks to
the carpet and says hey explain things
to us they say well I can't it's
classified that's sources and methods
and if you have people that have worked
in that space before you can really
start pushing back I'll say two things
the first is
to that point about needing people from
the inside to come out and explain
what's going on I mean this is what
project verdas does yeah they get
whistleblowers often sometimes it's a
sting sometimes it's a whistleblower
right so how many people work for
project veterans Veritas right now who
are literally the people at Big Tech
working on the censorship who said this
is bad I can't do this and then went to
Veritas said let's change it not to not
to uh dissimilar you working for the ca
coming out saying hey this is bad we
need to change it yeah however I will
also add the old saying once CIA always
CIA right so so sure I think this is why
a lot of people are well this in in the
chat they're all like fedcast
but I think the spook is here I feel
like it must be different you're
describing like being Green Beret taking
missile to office like you say like oh
yeah I didn't want to bomb in but like I
took an oath where it's like you have
this other class that like feels like
when they lose they get to manipulate
the system right you know what I mean
like I could see maybe you are a Fed but
at the same time you know I could see
that there is a division even within
that and to me that speaks to a lot of
the dissatisfaction with military like
the the lack of military recruiting that
we have right now I mean you if you guys
can't turn around and say the next guy
coming up hey like there are some
challenges but it was worth it then how
are we going to keep that system rolling
maybe we shouldn't I don't know how
we're going to keep our country I mean
that's a big thing like when we can't
recruit for the military like I'm
against all the escalations and all that
but we need to have a military if people
aren't willing I mean that's a huge
issue people aren't willing to join the
military you know the weirdest thing to
me is this um
this can it's it's like it's like a
demand for conspiracy it's a demand Ron
DeSantis starts giving people everything
they want he's opposes critical race
theory he opposes the gender ideology he
opens up the country he starts
implementing these policies then we
start hearing from just some people
they're like it's too good to be true
he's he's deep State he's got bad people
around him and I'm just like if you
can't
vote for exactly what you want you've
lost already yeah exactly so it's like
the best thing you can do is
support what
is good and what you need and want and
hope for the best but like politicians
lie I mean what can you expect the thing
that sucks is Mo is like most people
feel the same way and so that's why you
have the the you know the the
uniparty you get Democrats and
Republicans and people are like well I
don't really like the Democrats but I
really hate the Republicans so I'm going
to vote for the Democrats and then you
have people that are like well I really
hate the Democrats I don't like the
Republicans much but I'm going to vote
for the Republicans no one gets a
perfect candidate and I think that a lot
of the problem is people
look at our government as if it's a as
if it should be a top-down government
and they stop they don't realize or
don't think about the fact that the
people that are going to have the most
effect on their daily lives or their
local politicians their Congress people
if you write your Congress person you
may get a response if you write your
Senator you ain't getting a response you
write the president you ain't getting a
response but you go to your city council
you start going to school I've been
going to a lot of school board meetings
in this process I've had to be a
candidate and I mean that's school board
meetings and engaging with your Sheriff
I mean that right there that's the stuff
that actually affects people's everyday
lives a little bit different we had
harsh covid lockdown so we had the
overstaff of the federal government and
our governor as well but yeah that's
that's but it's still the local level
politicians that are going to battle the
federal government on your behalf right
yeah and you still need them legal in
local percent let's jump to this story
which is uh oh so spicy we got this one
from the daily mail before I'd read the
headline I just want to say do not take
medical advice from podcasters talk to
trusted medical professionals about
what's right for you because the daily
male says getting Pfizer's covet booster
and flu vaccine on the same day May
raise the risk of a stroke FDA says the
FDA says it okay the FDA the Food and
Drug Administration found the
preliminary link while scouring vaccine
injury databases after a separate safety
concern was raised about Pfizer's jab
earlier this month one of the country's
vaccine surveillance systems flagged a
possible association between the Omicron
specific shot and an elevated risk of
ischemic stroke among seniors over 65.
FDA officials who have been investing in
the link said most of the patients had
also received their flu shot on the same
day which might be a factor millions of
Americans got both shots at the same
time this winter following a major
public health Push by the White House in
September Dr Ashish Jah White House
coveted response coordinator said quote
I believe this is why God gave us two
arms one for the flu shot and the other
for the covet shot oh yo wait a minute I
mean this I don't know if this is
definitively the cause of why we're
hearing about more Strokes why more
excess death or heart attacks but the
White House was telling people to get
both they it's quoted and the FDA is now
saying there may be a link here so I
don't know I guess how long do you think
it'll be until they come out and
definitively be like oh yeah about all
that that was that was that was correct
so like is the FDA wrong right now to
suggest this I'll I'll frame it that way
for our friends over at YouTube at least
they put it out there I mean I do think
we're in this this uh this weird space
right now where I think our ruling
classes realize they got this whole
coveted thing completely and totally
wrong but because of you know Pride them
worrying about like any kind of
repercussions but then also just the
whole sunken cost fallacy like you
continue to double down it's really hard
to say you know what we got this wrong
especially since we were so harsh on all
the random people out there who said I
have questions I don't know if I want to
do that this is funny because it's like
uh it's a it's a casino dad joke when
you lose a bet you go well you know what
they say when you lose a bet just gamble
twice as much because you're not
supposed to do this
that's right and uh Oz is kind of crazy
for me to see the store I mean we got we
had so many crazy stories just come out
in the past couple of hours when we
started this show and what what had
happened was uh I think was a couple
weeks ago they said that they found a
potential signal between I think it was
Strokes I think it was Strokes I'm not
sure there was a signal between vaccines
and some negative side effect but
they're not sure if it was actually
correct now it looks like they're saying
the FDA is saying this
that they went in and they started
looking and said hey wait a minute maybe
it's because people are getting the
bulky shots at the same time
yeah that could explain a lot I mean I
feel like the FDA wouldn't come out and
even give up potentially there's maybe
something there unless they had to right
like they don't want to seed any
territory on this front it's not just
that I mean imagine you work for the FDA
and you're sitting there looking at this
document that says this thing and you're
thinking I'm gonna lose my job at Pfizer
when I retire from the FDA if I put this
report out but you really have no choice
yeah and the crazy thing is like the
vaccine if this was any other vaccine or
booster I think they would say hey wait
stop we don't know what's going on here
let's let's you know have a pause let's
study it but because they've invested so
much in it right now all we get is these
like kind of willy-nilly warnings
because it's the sacred covet vaccine
well I I have to I half agree with uh
Johnson and Johnson and AstraZeneca yeah
they did put a stop on those because I
think what was it AstraZeneca was the
blood clot one yeah and then Johnson
Johnson was blood clots but it was only
the one dose and there were other like
right core morbidities yeah that like
the U.S doesn't have AstraZeneca sure
and then I did you want to fact check
this one I'm pretty sure the US they
said hey we're gonna put a pause on the
Johnson and Johnson one because of a
risk of blood clotting or something like
that and then uh uh WebMD I think it is
and the American Heart Association have
come out and said that there is that
myocarditis is a rare side effect of the
MRNA vaccines so it seems like a lot of
the fears people had early on
are now just basically being affirmed by
powerful institutions and and health
organizations that being said I will
stress they also add their extremely
rare side effects but they do find these
links so I want to make sure people
don't look I know a lot of people are
outright either people are like either
everyone must be vaccinated or totally
anti-vaxx it's like it's it's fine to be
somewhere in the middle and just be like
look talk to a doctor
covid could be causing this it could be
a combination of things it could be like
you said they've invested too heavily in
this and they won't back down Johnson
Johnson uh pulled or the U.S pulled
Johnson Johnson because of a link to
blood clots in December 2021 and then
AstraZeneca was paused in Europe by a
bunch of different countries in uh May
of 2022. I think uh isn't some country
stopping the vaccine the MRNA vaccine
for like people under 29 was that Sweden
or something
one of those Scandinavian countries well
you there was a whole wave of countries
that paused uh Cove vaccines I think it
was Pfizer specifically really be for
young men because they saw the link to
myocarditis and all the heart issues and
then they kept raising it it went from
being like Oh well 12 to 18 and then it
I think in some countries it went all
the way up to like 45. we we got a
problem with this if the FDA is really
putting the story out because if they're
saying that a combination of vaccines
can cause problems then we've got to
have an inquiry on have we done studies
on the combination of all vaccines that
I don't think I don't think you really I
think it's very difficult to do this if
the conditions were different I don't
think that there's any question about
the fact that the FDA would be like stop
everything stop you can't put this out
blah blah blah Etc I think that that
that goes without saying the reason that
they're so tentative about this is
because they've for so long were pushing
so hard and demonized the population and
called people all the names that you
could possibly imagine yeah and and now
they're like oh oh well because they've
already destroyed their credibility and
they think that they're defending you
from terrible conspiracy right yeah
saying like well we can't give up this
front because then the conspiracy
theorists have won and they'll they'll
tell you all sorts of horrible things it
actually reminds me of conversations
people have about
um
preservatives and Foods right like if
you eat store manufactured food or
whatever all day you're actually putting
a ton of stuff into your body you don't
know about I don't know anything about
it really but like it is something you
wonder I can only imagine putting lots
of different types of vaccines that you
can't in a consistent way test their
interactions it's a gamble oh well you
can test their interactions it's just a
question of have we well and also like
you can't it would be difficult to
reproduce study after study after study
that they are able to consistently test
let's uh let's talk about the the actual
challenge here I mean the permutations
of com a vaccine combination
combinations is probably in the in the
billions or trillions so we actually do
have a challenge in this idea of of
Health technology
we make vaccines most of the vaccines
that people get have been tested and
tried out for decades we seem to be
doing all right I I've gotten a whole
bunch of crazy shots when I was
traveling the world yeah I'm totally
okay and so I know there's a lot of
people who are like staunchly anti-backs
we had Candace Owens on she she talked
about this on the members only show she
gave her her opinions on this but the
question is every time we come up with a
new medication we it would be impossible
to I'm not I'm not even not even
vaccines but any drug any drug so let's
say they come out with a new painkiller
they're gonna have to test what happens
if someone's on this painkiller and Drug
a drug B drug C drug D drug e drug f I
mean the combinations are going to be in
the in ridiculous numbers
now they do have like counter
indications like hey don't take this if
you're taking this so to the best of
their abilities they do track the stuff
but for the most part it seems what
happens is they give someone a
painkiller the person's also on a blood
thinner they then see the person have a
negative reaction they then you know
track this and say hey over the past
thousand combinations of this drugs we
saw negative reactions let's so it's
it's like the the the the studies are
happening in real time essentially I
think I guess what I'm trying to say is
any attempt we're gonna have at making
drugs or medical technology is going to
run into side effect problems it is and
and how we navigate that stuff I don't
know I think just being honest I mean
that I think the reason why we're seeing
so many people now that are outright
like militant anti-vaxxers is because
we've just they've been lying to us
about so many different things regarding
covid from the beginning that now it's
gone the completely different direction
where people are just like I don't want
any more vaccines I don't trust anything
you guys are saying and that's pretty
dangerous because I think if like a real
legit lethal virus hit the U.S Shores
Tomorrow there's a lot of people
probably myself included that would be
like I don't believe you I'm not going
to take that we talked about a few years
ago Ian brought up a really great point
we were all like no lockdowns lockdowns
are wrong and he said what if it was an
Airborne Ebola yeah and then we're like
okay that's an interesting point but you
know ultimately the conclusion we came
to was like if you choose to go out
during a pandemic it's your choice and
if you don't want to stay inside lock
your doors but there is an interesting
question I'd have right
a lot of people are essentially
anti-vaxx but my question legitimately
maybe I'll do a pause I don't know if I
can phrase it get enough characters to
make a pull on this one but
people are you know people have gotten
coveted some people have said it's not
that bad some people have said it was
pretty bad some people said it was
apocalyptically bad for me it was
nightmarishly that it was the worst
illness I've ever gotten I've had the
flu before and I was pale and shaking
yeah I got coveted I actually called the
hospital oh really yeah yeah because I
it was bad my my temperature was really
low my breathing was very heavy and I it
was pain all over and then I ended up
getting monoclonal antibodies I've told
the story a million times my question is
this for the people who are not trusting
of the government
if you actually witnessed people
suffering Ebola symptoms like you walk
outside in the streets and people have
blood coming out of their eyes and
they're hacking up black and they're
going on they're falling over
and then the government came in a truck
and they were like we've got the vaccine
quick you need to get it now would you
guys accept it well think of it
I just think there's been so much trust
burned that you would have to see I mean
people nowadays not not everybody but I
think there would be a significant
portion of our population who would be
like I don't care if you put it on the
news I need to see it with my own eyes
until then I think you guys are screwing
no no but that's what I mean let's say
you personally yeah saw people outside
hacking up black and bleeding from their
eyes and then slumping over and
convulsing and then a truck pulls up and
they come out and they say Mr Kent we've
got vaccines for you in your
neighborhood please come we're gonna
administer administer them to you would
you say okay to that yeah I think at
that point yeah it makes sense it's
tough though it is still a hard question
some people would say no I understand
why they'd say no they'd be like dude I
don't know what's going on in in um
where was it Nigeria where the where was
the Ebola thing happening do you
remember that a few years ago yeah it's
like near Congo so people were running
from the doctors yeah and they and and
the doctors are trying to stop the
spread of Ebola and the people like I
don't trust you and so they would flee
and then actually spread more Ebola yeah
it's it's hot it's a tough situation
yeah I think that I think that the
situation would really boil down to the
you know the context if you're like if
you're looking at people that are you
know vomiting blood and stuff the risk
is probably far greater of dying from
that than from a uh a vaccine the reason
people are are worked up about covet is
because covid for a lot of people was
not as was not deadly if you were in
good health and you didn't have you know
uh with the contributing factors and
stuff and that's right part of why
people were upset it's like I had to
take this these have risks I was healthy
or I am healthy I probably wouldn't have
a problem you know I kind of feel like
uh the the highest risk demographic was
the older people people with
comorbidities so it really does feel
like politicians who are scared for
themselves told everyone else they have
to do it yeah so that they would be
better off yeah I mean I've known people
that's how like some young moms get told
they need to get the flu vaccine right
they'll say like there's a bad flu
alcohol break in our city and you have a
newborn baby and if you don't pass down
like you're breastfeeding or whatever
the antibodies for it then your baby is
at risk and an infant at this age can't
handle the flu right and so they get the
flu vaccine I'm not saying there's
anything wrong with flu vaccine I'm just
giving it as an example uh when maybe
they would have opted not to because
they felt like they are actually
protecting someone else I think that's
how the government sold to a lot of
people if you have elderly parents do
you want to be the one that gave them
covid right or do you want to be kept
away from them like it put people in a
really difficult position and
unfortunately coveted was not a
clear-cut example of who of how bad the
symptoms were right like if someone's
vomiting a black goo and
okay I guess I'm in but like right you
know there's a limit right but also like
a really bad fever can be extremely
dangerous right a high enough fever you
can have seizures so there are things
that look that aesthetically don't look
as bad but they are also uh terrible and
can be devastating the reason I bring
this up before we go on to the next
story is
we just we should just we had this
project Veritas expose of a guy who is
either a consultant working at Pfizer
director or a director advisor saying
that he believes the Wuhan lab leak is
likely where this came from because
covet couldn't have come from somewhere
else or whatever that's his opinion
in the in the in in 2020 this was the
big Theory people were saying that they
believed it was a bioweapon leak from a
lab yeah if that theory were true then
it makes more sense that the governments
of the world in panic desperately tried
to make a vaccine to stop a bio weapon
Elite from a lab in which case the
vaccine it makes sense why they're like
you have to take this yeah because you
think about it this way they're you know
fauci is providing this funding the lab
the the lab leak thing happens and then
he's probably going like oh man oh that
thing I made is getting everywhere we
got to get a vaccine everybody's got to
take it that makes that makes a lot of
sense to me and then if people are
having blood clots and other weird you
know problems it makes more sense
Occam's razor would suggest that covet
is causing these things and not the
vaccines because what you'd have to
believe then
is if you think it was the vaccines
causing it that Not only was covet a Buy
open leak from a lab but then after it
released they went now let's make
everything a whole lot worse okay so
then it's not a lab leak it's an
intentional release and a fake look I'm
not saying I know for sure one way or
the other I'm just saying it's it's way
more Fantastical to believe that yeah
but I don't know I just don't know right
and and I can only say this
there's no functional official narrative
like the average person is not trusting
of the government at this point because
the stories just do not work for people
so the only thing I can really say is do
what uh be like Joe Rogan find a medical
professional that you trust that can
answer your questions and then you know
like I always mentioned I called Joe I
always have to shout Joe out because
they dragged him so much for this when
his whole position was like I called a
doctor and asked them what to do because
their position was going to 7-Eleven
parking lot yeah yeah I mean for real
shot let's uh let's jump to this next
story we got this from uh The Daily
Beast
Georgia Governor activates 1 000
National Guard troops amid cop City
protest
I just really love how everybody is
framing this this is not a protest this
is domestic terrorists who have been
charged with domestic terrorism who shot
a cop and put him in the hospital while
trying to seize territory these are
individuals who crossed state lines with
semi-automatic weapons they did yeah
that's right I mean that's the most
shocking part and then when the cops
they fire bombed houses they fire bombed
houses houses yeah under construction
houses to make make sure the context is
clear they were building houses they
came in and they torched them a guy was
driving his truck they firebombed it he
fled they flipped his truck over these
are dangerous violent Psychopathic
terrorists gunfights gun fights with
police yeah and then when the police
went and moved in in the sky shot a cop
put him in the hospital severe injury
not critical severe they shot back
killed the guy you get leftist media
saying oh the police killed this guy you
get the activists coming out then the
activists call for the assassination of
cops now in Atlanta they are deploying
one thou or they're activating 1 000
National Guard Brian Kemp is declaring a
15-day state of emergency in Georgia
amid the civil unrest a thousand
National Guard trips are being activated
I guess my question is this
I got a couple questions actually is
this the beginning of a new Summer of
Love is this stuff gonna going to
continually get worse do you guys think
and what should be done about it it'll
keep getting worse uh if we don't take
the action that Brian Kemp and then the
Atlanta police are taking right now so
as somebody from the Pacific Northwest
who had their communities absolutely
ravaged by antifa Big Time kudos to
Georgia for not putting up with this
crap and actually taking measures to
prevent it from spreading because in
2020 we did unfortunately our government
in Seattle and in Portland they just let
it go and it's it's continued to this
day and here we are in 2023 so I hope
they continue to really crack down these
guys charge them with domestic terrorism
charges
I agree
I mean I'm not I'm not I'm not a huge
fan of of uh the militarization of the
police and stuff but if you have
armed groups
that are causing that kind of chaos and
and Mayhem you're going to have a
serious problem with your Society like
Atlanta is going to have a mess until
those people get clean until they clean
up the situation and that if that means
that you have to start throwing people
in jail you have to because they're
they're ignoring the rights of the other
people in Atlanta the problem isn't oh
you know it's it's it's the problem
isn't that the Atlanta police are are
heavy-handed or whatever the problem is
that there are actual anarchists and
Communists looking to start a revolution
in Atlanta right now and that's there's
no two ways about it if you talk to them
they call themselves revolutionaries if
you talk to them they will say that you
know that they are looking to engage the
cops give them the fight they want yeah
Joe did you ever get an Explorer good I
was just gonna ask if you ever got an
explanation from like y'all's government
over why they didn't do more you know
why the inaction was you know status quo
no we got basically nothing but
gaslighting I mean they'll they'll tell
us that hey there was protesters and you
know the elected officials down in
Portland and Seattle would even go as
far as to say as like this is just
peaceful protests all the all the
cliches of you know Summer of Love that
came from Seattle that came from the
Jazz I mean up until they showed up in
her neighborhood then she called the
cops and she wanted them the heck out of
there yeah no they're still there's been
there's still there's still no
accountability yeah that was hilarious I
mean and these these guys they didn't
just trash Portland and Seattle they
came into even some of the rural dishes
because they were emboldened because no
one was stopping them we needed the
government to step in and they didn't so
good on Georgia the Communists won a
revolution give them the fight they want
they're looking they're literally
looking to fight the government
government go give them the fights well
arrest them lock them up and stop the
fight well that's that's what's gonna
happen I mean you're basically going to
stomp a mud hole in their butt the
problem is
it's not it's not stopping
because they don't do anything right but
when the cops did go to try and confront
this this is what happens when you
ignore the problem yeah the police went
to confront a bunch of far leftists who
came across state lines with weapons
with semi-automatic weapons and rifles
and they shot a cop yeah the cop was in
severe condition was brought to the
hospital to get surgery they returned
fire and self-defense killing one of
these guys if they had just arrested
them but the problem is
I think there's two things
you've got Democrats who are unwilling
to confront the left wing of their own
party because it empowers them and then
you've got members of the democratic
party who agree with them yeah so you
know you guys I hope you have your
whiskey ready or whatever it is you
drink because Civil War
look I've talked about it quite a bit I
don't know exactly what shape or
whatever will happen how it's going to
happen but we're at the point now where
it's 2023 and we're hearing that not
only have we graduated from antifa
sitting in the street taking over street
corners we now have people traveling
from across the country to seize parts
of prop big portions of land shooting at
cops
fire bombing the city calling for
assassinations and being charged with
domestic terrorism we are now out of the
territory of antifa through a milkshake
and we are now in the territory of
antifa is coalescing shooting at cops
firebombing buildings again
and being charged with domestic
terrorism like the escalation is is
happening yeah will it be isolated to
Atlanta or is the summer going to be
another Summer of Love yeah I mean
unfortunately that answer like is really
up to antifa yeah I mean because we've
given them all the initiative I I hope
they keep doing what they're doing in
Georgia so maybe they'll move out of the
South and come back to the Pacific
Northwest unfortunately or New York City
but until these guys are actually
targeted and the crazy thing is that the
federal government as opposed to chasing
down every single you know grandmother
who is anywhere near the capitol on
January 6 or going after parents that
show up at school board meetings maybe
they should be going after the people
that are killing people on our streets
and burning out our entire cities like
use the FBI for that we talked about
this a few days ago when they when the
Mike Pence story happened where they
find documents in his house or whatever
and I'm like what if what if we're
dealing with a Tit for Tat what if we're
dealing with a fractured doj where of
course like you're talking about the CIA
but not every single person in the CIA
is woke and not every single person in
the CIA agrees with you on the
Constitution or is anti-woope you're
gonna have a mix I've talked to people
who worked intelligence I've got I get
emails from them I get messages and they
say like listen it's the same in here as
it is out there yeah there are some more
people there are some not woke people
most people don't care don't want to be
involved but the woke people speak up
they get passes so I'm wondering if
the doj goes after Trump
Trump then is house rated so you'll get
some element of the FBI getting angry
and saying I'm sick of this and then
finally putting their foot down and
saying we're going after Joe Biden all
of a sudden Joe Biden's lawyers are like
yep yep yep yeah we have them we have
them here take them we're cooperated
we're cooperating and then the
anti-trump anti you know Republican
faction because oh yeah you go after
Biden we're gonna go after Pence and
then Pence is people like yup yup we
found these documents we found these
documents I'm wondering if
you know the question is why
are they going after everybody
and is it possibly a Tit for Tat where
we're seeing different factions within
the executive branch just targeting
their political enemies yeah I mean
that's
a possibility I think this could just be
one big administrative State Flex for
them just to say hey we've got dirt on
all you guys and at any point in time
we're going to find something that whole
you know show me the man I'll show you
the crime I feel like a lot of that's
going on right now because this is a
very big Power Play if you're the
administrative state within the course
of two weeks to say hey Republican and
Democrat maybe you guys had Ambitions
for 2024 we just found some paperwork
that's not straight that's that's a good
point it may be an attempt to regain
control of the system a hard whip crack
to both parties we own you yeah and by I
mean Biden's been compromised six ways
to Sunday by so many different entities
that whoever you know installed him and
propped him up and got him into office
whether whichever pathway you believe
that that took place Biden was
definitely propped up they've got so
much dirt on this guy that it was just a
matter of them deciding when you know
it's like oh is it gonna be the
classified documents barisma yeah but it
seems like they could just tell him it
seems like they'd be like Joe
have have a nice retirement and he'd be
like okay I feel like he doesn't want to
I mean he kept saying before uh like
around Christmas he was like oh well
I'll make a decision I'll make an
announcement about 2024 yeah in January
and we're all going to think about it
and then two days later he kept saying
people like oh maybe Jill doesn't want
him to run and then Judy said I was like
oh no Jill definitely wants him to run I
mean they didn't release his annual
physical like they have been super cagey
about him this whole time and he has
been insistent that he will run again so
I think Joe is not as submissive as they
would like him to be yeah uh but he's
not in good shape no he's not I mean and
that's the thing that he's he's been
compromised he went through all this
risk to be compromised now he's finally
got what he wanted I don't think he's
gonna have a fight and he's got people
around him that benefit from him being
yeah so I do think there's going to be
some you know behind the scenes fighting
there
I think that you're kind of at a point
where if you're not Vindicated now about
the whole Civil War stuff I don't see I
mean it would have to be what was that I
said I could be wrong I was just what is
already going on well that's that's kind
of what I've been saying and the point I
often bring up is like guys I'm just
reading these these news articles about
National Security assessments like my
opinion on this is rooted in reading a
bunch of news stories that say National
Security Experts well I mean what did
you have you're like a former CIA uh uh
analyst yeah wrote a book saying we're
entering the second phase which brings
us into Civil War and I'm like okay you
know
maybe I guess buy chickens you got
chickens yeah we got chickens yeah we
gotta have chickens yeah yeah eggs now
are so expensive yeah and uh it's become
a crazy issue but it's funny because
look I'm not gonna tell you why eggs are
expensive like I'm just gonna say you
need to have chickens because you need
to be self-sufficient but if you really
want to know a bird flu hit chickens and
then they started culling chickens yeah
so a lot of people I I had someone say
to me you're lying about inflation and
eggs you're blaming Joe Biden when it
was a bird flu that killed all these
chickens and I'm like I never said any
of that but it wasn't the bird for the
killer chickens it was orders by the
government to kill all your chickens so
apparently they were they were
instructing people to Cull their flocks
because of fear of the of the flu and
they're trying to slow it down right we
got a backyard flock they're fairly
isolated we've got to worry about
chicken diseases or anything like that
they're not going to chicken school
they're not kissing
they're locked down yeah they're locked
down they're they're wrapped up you know
but but that being said considering
everything that's going on
there was a story I was reading the
other day about some 23 year old woman
from I think Seattle
she leaves the city buys a farm in the
middle of nowhere and is now prepping
and it's just like when you get a 23
year old like tick-tock influencer
one like this Urban woman who's decided
this is the path for her yeah it kind of
says a lot because it used to be if you
were a prepper they mocked you right now
it's the cool thing to do to go on Tick
Tock and be like yeah I'm prepping yep
nobody makes fun of Preppers anymore
yeah no well the peppers are the one
sitting back with the whiskey and the
cigar laughing at us saying I ain't got
anything to worry about the pictures of
the ones that were like when when covid
hit off we were just like
okay
all right what now because everything
you oh I didn't have to run to the store
but that's that's that's just overtly
true I was at a gas station in like
Arizona or something during the
lockdowns and
this lady I asked her because like the
the gas station was open everything
seemed to find nobody was wearing masks
and I was like it's interesting and then
I asked her I was like have you guys
noticed anything about like with the
lockdown she's like I wear Preppers we
don't care and I was like Ranchos we got
three months worth of toilet paper we're
not worried about toilet paper I started
laughing and then she like looks her
husband and she's like right and he's
like we got everything yeah and I'm like
okay like these people literally don't
care what's going on they're probably
laughing all the way to the toilet paper
closet yeah the Fortress of Solitude in
New Hampshire dude I was fine but can I
just mention how crazy that like
everybody knows how crazy that was but
let's just bring it up again those
videos of people fighting over toilet
paper
yeah it was wild yeah absolutely wild I
think a trip to Seattle would probably
make most people want to go prep I mean
if you're if you're prep skeptical like
just go to Seattle maybe downtown
Portland and you'll know why let's talk
about uh the end of the world I guess
yeah we have this story from Newsweek
Germany says quiet part out loud about
Ukraine war
you know if you Google search Germany
declares war on Russia this is the story
you get and uh the reason why is
Germany's foreign minister said we are
at War
so it's not a formal declaration of war
she's literally
you know I would say in the colloquial
sense she is declaring that they are at
war with Russia yeah this basically
means NATO basically means us yeah that
loves Michael Tracy tweeted Jeremy
declares war on Russia right posting
this video of her saying it and then he
got fact checked on Twitter saying there
has been no formal declaration of war
and he was like no one said there was
I'm saying that she is declaring war on
Russia so we have we also have this
story which goes along with it
Russia says it will consider the
deployment of German Leopard 2 tanks as
the use of nuclear dirty bomb if they
use shells containing uranium core all
right there we go so Russia is going to
come out and say you started the nuclear
war first yeah all of this is escalation
everything that we do to help Ukraine is
escalation anything anyone in the west
and all of it to Russia looks is Russia
is taking it for exactly what it is
which is every Western NATO country
trying to help Ukraine defeat Russia
there is not a situation where Russia
gets beaten back
and and and leaves uh leaves crime here
and stuff like that and that's what a
lot of people are talking about I don't
um I can't imagine why anyone believes
that that would happen well you're
you're running yeah right so uh 2024
people have a chance to vote for you you
will be in what's your view on how we
handle a situation like this cut off
Ukraine no involvement what do you think
send weapons we need to move towards
de-escalation the little bit of Leverage
that we have right now is that we're
we're bankrolling all this escalation I
mean the German the Germans right now
are getting all of the attention but a
couple months ago we had Dick Durbin on
the floor of the of the Congress saying
that we're at war with Russia Biden has
said you can't remain in power he's used
regime change rhetoric the same stuff we
said about Saddam and Gaddafi so we've
continued to drive the Train on
escalation I would like to use the
leverage that we have to get both sides
of the negotiating table we also threw a
huge uh sanctions package against the
Russians so I think we're in a position
right now and our time window for this I
think is unfortunate fortunately very
short where we could say look Ukraine if
you guys want any more aid for anything
you have to be actively involved in
negotiations with the Russians working
towards the ceasefire and then offer
Putin sanctions relief and also make a
guarantee to him that we're not going to
expand NATO like NATO should not be on
the border of Russia that was the
containment doctrine that got us through
the Cold War without any kind of nuclear
escalation like this but right now the
only elected officials I hear talking
about de-escalation it's a handful of
Republicans in the house and the Senate
and then the only world leader is Donald
Trump that's saying that hey
negotiations are what we need to be
doing it's crazy
the Doomsday Clock gets moved 90 seconds
to midnight because of the Ukraine war
not that I think a Doomsday Clock means
anything other than a handful of
scientists are like we're going to blow
ourselves up I just happen to agree with
their opinion that this is a dangerous
and incorrect direction to go but look
Kevin McCarthy is wearing the Ukraine
flag stuff it's the only thing I see in
this is they're not going to back down
there we are it's a bad Grace headed
right for the edge of a cliff yeah it is
100 and then the crazy thing to me is
that no one's no one in our leadership
has had the respect for the American
people to explain to them this is why
you hear a bunch of rhetoric you hear
that you're either with us or you're a
Putin sympathizer I get called that
occasionally you know but they don't say
hey guys
um we're actually going to have your
your elected representatives as per the
U.S Constitution go and argue the case
they can come back to the district and
say hey this is this is why we think
this is important and if things go wrong
we could end up in a war in Eastern
Europe are you guys good with that you
guys you guys want to sign on to that
but they don't do that I kind of feel
like uh these people in government
should should play some poker because
I've been I've been playing a bunch of
poker online I played it at the casino
for the first time and uh you learn the
lesson about folding for those that play
poker I'm not like good or like I'm not
comprehend to be good or anything but
like the first time I started playing
I'm like I got no idea what's going on
and then I'm like yeah I'll bet I'm like
oh that was dumb I just lost all my
money and eventually you learn like I
made a few bets I thought my hand was
good but now I think he's probably
better he's pushing hard I'm gonna cut
my losses I've lost on this I've lost
money on this I'm losing this fight but
the ultimate winning position in the end
is going to be to accept that and
Retreat and it feels like none of these
people can accept that that you're both
raising the stakes against each other
right and in the end there's no winner
nobody's taken home any prize no it's
going to be a heap of Ash and nuclear
waste yeah and the best bet is to be
like we lost 100 billion dollars
you're going to lose the Don bass region
yeah or you're going to lose the planet
yeah I mean or just say hey look this I
mean the the conflict between the the
border of Russia and Ukraine has been
going along on longer than America has
been a country and so for us just to say
get to the negotiating table what you
guys work out on your own border that is
up to you we're not going to further
escalate this by pushing NATO up but
what we want is we want the Bloodshed
here to stop because right now who's
dying it's ukrainians are dying they're
getting thrown into the meat grinder the
Russians don't care about casualties
like for all the the military analysts
out there who are like oh the the
Russians you know they can't sustain
this they they haven't lost in
comparison to other times Russia's
fought Wars they haven't even come close
to what they're willing to lose and
Russia's just look it's it's a much
bigger country than Ukraine there's
going to have to be some form of realism
injected into this Russia is the zap
Brannigan of countries
sending wave after wave of their own men
to die until they finally win this is
this is what they were famous for with
the uh I correct me if I'm wrong because
I'm not like I store anything but I was
reading about in World War II yeah
Russia opted for mass production of low
quality weapons and tanks but lots of
them yeah so while the West is like
let's make the best tank in the world
and then when it blows up you're like
okay it took a long time Russia was like
get a bunch of metal boxes and just keep
sending them out and don't stop yeah
that's what they're doing with their
artillery right now I mean there's a lot
of talk about it we got to send them
javelins we got to send them tanks we're
going to send them high Mars and the
Russians are just like we're gonna
pulverize these towns and it's horrible
they shouldn't be doing this but they're
going to pulverize the towns World War
One World two Style with artillery with
missile systems and then they're gonna
have their mercenaries come in who are
mostly released prisoners come in yeah
and if a couple thousand of them die
they don't care most people don't
realize that artillery wins Wars like
especially in Europe like artillery has
killed more human beings in war than any
other means because artillery is the
king of battle like if they put
artillery on the on the on the border
they can level like I don't know how far
artillery goes 20 30 40 miles yeah it's
also
um it's the risk assessment how much are
you willing to lose and I think it's
fair to say Russia is willing to lose a
lot more than we are absolutely oh yeah
and that puts us in a very weak position
when it comes to leverage and when it
comes to getting getting called that
should be obvious sorry this fight is
just so different than anything
Americans can really compare to because
Ukraine and Russia have such a shared
history it's very complicated uh to say
that like we in the beginning of this
there was a call between Vladimir Putin
and Biden and Vladimir Putin just asked
like will you promise that Ukraine won't
join NATO and Biden was like I can't do
that like why are you getting involved
in this Regional debate like fight which
obviously it's violence terrible but it
is so much more complicated I mean
zielinski I just wrote about this today
but zielinski in December was like we
should kick out one of the churches
because uh Eastern Orthodoxy is the
dominant religion in Ukraine and there
are two sacks and they split uh in 2020
I believe and now zelinsky's like if the
if the church reports to Moscow which it
does I'd don't want them operating here
I mean it is such a divisive region
already we have nothing to compare it to
and I don't understand like why our
leaders would think this is something
that we should just just insert
ourselves into and if we get it wrong
the consequences are nuclear war I mean
we just got out of 20 years of
disastrous war in the Middle East but
this isn't going to be like the wars in
the Middle East where we can be like you
know what the American people don't care
anymore you guys just want to leave
Afghanistan and we just fly we fly I
mean it was a tragedy we lost 13 we
didn't need to lose we don't really fly
out faster you know and the same thing
we left our acne to go back then we left
again and we can kind of absorb all that
because we're a strong Nation it was
tragic we shouldn't have done it but
this is completely different and I think
we have a bunch of people who are
thinking like oh a fight in Ukraine
that's going to be sort of like we just
did in the global war on terror you know
worst case scenario like we just leave
who cares like that's that's not the way
this is going to play out no not at all
yeah Russia's got a bunch of nuclear
weapons right in their U.S and they're
right and they're saying that the use of
these uh uranium core shells will be
using nuclear dirty bombs yeah so Russia
could come out and just claimed they did
the news reporting is there and they're
going to say hey they're using nuclear
weapons and then Russia is going to make
an announcement like we have no choice
but to respond in kind this is the fault
of the West for the escalation of the
use of nuclear weapons yeah but I also
kind of Wonder like how much do
appearances matter you're right so one
of the reasons these the US and Russia
are trying to avoid dramatic escalation
like nuclear weapons is because we still
have to trade with other countries and
if the US went nuts and said started
firing nukes we might get isolated we
people are going to get mad at us so
obviously that factors in but if Russia
is looking at the end of their Nation or
even Putin at the end of his power yeah
he's going to be like I don't care what
anyone thinks right it's about what
you're going to lose at some point
you're like if we do nothing
we are done yeah so even if we can find
a way to navigate this even if these of
these weapons will piss off our allies
it's either piss off our allies or cease
to exist yeah yeah they're going to pick
the obvious one yeah anyway through the
kitchen sink at him right away the the
sanctions package where we just
completely and totally cut them off in
the west that took away our ability to
make that more gradual so now I think we
just need to start giving him an exit
ramp from that so he's not beholden but
to China right but then I mean the whole
thing is just so much more uh escalation
and we're just heading towards this
point where we're not gonna be able to
walk it back and plus there's so many
experts right now who are trying to
predict like what's going to happen next
here and there right now in the fog of
battle no one can predict what's going
to happen next and there's a lot of
folks that are giving the American
people some sort of false hope that like
we're completely and totally in control
we're gonna we're gonna give the
ukrainians these tanks and we know
exactly what the repercussions are going
to be I was mentioning a moment ago that
uh the atomic scientists move the
Doomsday Clock 90 Seconds To Midnight
meaning we're very close to the end of
days they say it's mostly nuclear
Annihilation some climate change but
also misinformation yeah and that being
said I have a new reason why the world's
about to end with the story from the
hill BuzzFeed to use AI to produce
select content news quiz and games
website BuzzFeed will use AI in the
coming months to create content the
company's top executive said this week
and so it begins I tweeted about that
this morning all right so I'm sorry I
retweeted someone uh Joe weisenthal
tweeted about it if you look at the let
me see if I can find it real quick the
stock price for BuzzFeed jumped through
the roof when they announced this when
they announced that yeah Joe weisen
thought let's check in and see how
investors like the idea of using AI to
replace journalists the price jumped
from one like 122 or something like that
123. yeah to 190. wow I mean that's
that's a pretty hefty increase a big
jump so here's why I think this is
apocalyptic the AI is going to create a
a recursion Loop or a feedback loop
among the reading public who use the
site and we will come to a point where
in 5 five years if you know someone who
strictly consumes BuzzFeed they'll walk
up to you and go like man do you hear
about that that corn factory and on the
moon and you're gonna be like what the
the corn thing that Trump did with the
moon and you're gonna be like what are
you talking about yeah you didn't see
this
I was reading on BuzzFeed and you're
gonna be like BuzzFeed is AI generated
content the AI is going to start
figuring out what you click on and it's
going to create a psychotic amalgam of
clickable things yeah we've already seen
this happen on YouTube if this is the
direction we the direction we go
holy crap I mean AI is a whole nother
realm that I think we just need to slow
down and really assess how we're going
to use this because I mean this could
like you said rapidly spiral out of
control I mean it's gonna be fun uh do
you know what Elsa gate is I don't know
this is this thing that happened on
YouTube uh several years ago was it like
five years ago now five years ago it's
back it's back I mean I saw some video
from uh you know mudahar I forget his
name was some ordinary game or whatever
it's been talking about how a lot of the
content that used to be on Elsa gay has
now returned it's back on the platform
so Elsa gate was there were a whole
bunch of videos on YouTube of people who
would dress up like Elsa the Joker and
who else was it it was a joker Elsa
um Frozen yeah Elsa it was Spiderman
Spiderman Joker and Elsa yeah and you'd
see these weird videos pop up with a 100
million views and there's no talking
it's just Elsa running around and the
Joker is going like this and Spider-Man
is fighting with them some started
getting even weirder where the Joker
would be injecting Elsa with a giant
syringe and she's pregnant about to give
birth
what was happening was the YouTube
algorithm was selecting for what they
thought what it thought people wanted
what did people want to watch Hitler The
Joker Spider-Man Elsa so people started
making videos that combined all of these
things so that the algorithm would
recommend them more than anything else
it's the craziest thing ever and then
what started happening was another
component of this was the AI was
recommending content so people created
AI to create content which brings me to
what BuzzFeed is doing you started
seeing videos pop up of cartoon children
drinking urine
and injecting each other with syringes
and getting pregnant other just really
weird freaky things a whole lot of
drinking urine was the weird thing yeah
so what was happening was an AI an out
that someone someone got some kind of
like machine learning algorithm to scan
YouTube to figure out what people were
clicking on and then combine all of the
hottest things into one video put them
up there to to reverse exploit the
algorithm people are making tons of
money on this yeah creepy Nursery Rhyme
videos where Hitler's doing Tai Chi with
and he's got a a woman's body and with
the Hulk yeah yeah no no joke did you
laugh but it's like seriously now
imagine this I believe you little kids
were being handed iPads the parents
would would turn on nursery rhymes hand
to the kid and leave yeah the kid would
then be staring at the screen watching
Hitler do tai chi with a woman's body so
what's gonna happen to these kids when
they get older now we're hearing
buzzfeed's going to use AI to produce
select content perhaps they will have a
human being screen the content after
it's produced perhaps they're going to
start laying everybody off and they're
going to create what's the equivalent of
event vending machine for internet
content
yeah end of days man BuzzFeed did have a
couple really big layoffs I can't
imagine what those writers are thinking
right now you know well that yeah that
too like Google Microsoft Amazon they're
all laying everybody off as well so yeah
I mean what do we do after this like
what happens when everything's automated
I mean in a society that's been you know
progressively moving towards you know
getting away from any kind of religion
or any kind of moral Foundation just
saying that hey we are our own masters
like this this is this is where you end
up we're basically saying that humans
are irrelevant like you don't really
need humans I mean because we just keep
automating more and more things and then
AI comes in and ai's even better than
automation you know and now it's
replacing what should be creative
content I've seen a lot of the art
that's being done right now it's good I
mean it's scary and so then it's like
are they replacing human artists like
have we have we thought about that this
is the funny thing because a lot of
people are talking about this that we
used to believe automation would replace
labor jobs yeah and now we're learning
It's Quickly replacing creative jobs in
White Collar jobs it's writing the news
it's making the art it's doing the math
but you still need someone to go into
the coal mine with the hat with a rack
attack or something whatever they use AI
is not fixing your plumbing no AI is not
mining sulfur for us right the most the
most brutal job so literally one of the
things that uh musk is trying to do with
the uh robot that he's building is build
something that can do the actual tasks
like that yeah
so much closer yeah that crazy robot you
see that video oh yeah those things no
no the the advancements on the what's it
called Pac-Man
p-e-t-m-a-man I think is the one where
it like pushes the wood plank up jumps
up and then hands the guy throws the guy
his tool bag and then does a front flip
or something that one might not be pet
man I tweeted I can't wait to be running
full speed from these things after I ran
uh you know Food Depot because right
robots are controlling everything or
whatever
I think that's where we're ahead of yeah
Black Mirror did that episode where the
robo dogs are chasing everybody and uh
you know we can we can pretend like it's
all science fiction and silly but oh
that's where we're going man I mean I
think the effect is to make people more
discouraged right like if you are a
teenager right now and you love art but
you see what AI is producing like what's
even the importance of doing it right if
you're looking at videos of people you
know or like robots doing whatever like
you don't see a point in entering that
field if you know it's already doomed
right if you know it's over and that
makes you more malleable to the
government and to basically anyone who
wants to mislead you right for whatever
purpose they have uh you're not
motivated to build your own life because
it all seems like it's over it's the
biggest black pill there is yeah the
craziest thing is
we've talked about the singularity the
point I I guess we would call this The
Event Horizon the point at which AI is
good enough to improve its own code and
we're almost there yeah uh people have
been posting about how they use chat GPT
to write apps for them yep they'll be
like write me an app that can do this
and it goes it just gives you all the
code the weird the crazy thing that I've
heard people talk about with AI writing
its own code and stuff like that is once
it actually becomes capable of doing
that
your people aren't going to really know
the capabilities where the limits are
because AI can will learn from itself
and will make changes and update itself
and it there's no reason yeah there's no
reason that it's going to believe
there's no reason for us to believe that
it's going to either inform humans yeah
or feel obligated to even interact with
humans no this is the worst thing about
it so the Event Horizon if you guys are
familiar with the it's the point at
which you can't escape the black hole
it's not the center of the black hole
you're not in the black hole it's when
you're in its gravitational field that's
what I think we're about to hit with
chat GPT and these other I mean they're
saying chat GPT could replace Google but
it's writing Pro code it's writing
programs we're at the point now where
we're slowly being sucked in and there's
no way out we will get to the point
where it will write its own code and
that is the singularity where the
machine exponentially improves itself
the more it improves itself the faster
it improves itself and eventually there
will be a giant glowing orb floating
around changing reality or doing who
knows what it can do yeah knowing
everything about the universe
discovering everything within an instant
here's the best part
what are the parameters
by which the AI
functions what what what is the what is
the direction what we know is that chat
GPT is woke AF yeah you ask it like did
Rachel Maddow spread coveted
misinformation and says no she didn't
say okay well she literally did but it
was it was it the people who worked on
it were woke
so here's what happens with AI
as we talked about with Elsa gate
YouTube says we want an algorithm that
will find us content longer than 10
minutes that people really enjoy
watching because they wanted to find
Game of Thrones they were like we've got
billions of minutes and hours of content
certainly Game of Thrones is somewhere
in all of these monkeys on typewriters
right Shakespeare must exist right right
the algorithm did not bring them Game of
Thrones it brought them Hitler doing Tai
Chi whilst nursery rhymes with a woman's
body yeah because the algorithm didn't
the humans don't understand the humans
are we're looking at
the the universe the vastness of the
universe and they said you know what I
noticed
10 minute videos that people watch for a
long time
that's what they want to watch find me
these things no the AI then went into
the depths of the universe beyond human
sight and found psychotic nonsense that
fat that fit those parameters so once we
get to the singularity and the AI is
running things we're going to be walking
around talking about corn
you're gonna be you're gonna walk you're
gonna we're gonna be sitting on the show
and we're gonna be like did you see the
corn Surplus seven percent corn
President Biden is corn and the reason I
say corn is because it is a principal
food product produced in the U.S the AI
is going to say humans like corn produce
corn content corn is what humans love
the most and then all of a sudden the
only news you'll get will be like the
latest corn updates the latest corn
modifications the latest corn deliveries
and we won't even know we could be in it
right now was that kid who trended on
Tick Tock corn kid and like they made
the song being like it's a corn have you
seen this oh I haven't seen that it was
just some some on the ground reporter
like asking kids like what's your
favorite food and this kid was like it's
corn it's got like juice yeah it's got
these film that's going on and like it
was so big that Tick Tock changed their
bio to like its corn uh and it became a
song and like it was crazy so it's
interesting that you are foreshadowing
this I'm saying that let's let's already
know who our new president will be corn
kid that's right let's let's jump to the
story from NBC News I really want to
talk about this too because we're
talking about the apocalypse tick tocks
girl with the list inspires more honest
conversations about the pitfalls of
pregnancy
I was not prepared for what happened to
me and the school system didn't tell me
either this is this viral thing that's
going around on Tick Tock it's Uni's
pros and cons list for having children
it's actually just a list trying to
scare people into not having kids but
primarily basically women not men it's
talking about all the horrible things
that happen why you shouldn't have kids
and I see this and my thought is just we
are being domesticated as humans whether
intentionally or otherwise
and now there are viral Trends among
young women telling them not to have
children
the end result of this is fairly obvious
Japan just came out the Prime Minister
said the country is on the brink of
collapse because they only had 800 000
babies last year it's crazy that's crazy
that's one of the last acts of Shinzo
Abe have sex is that what he said he was
telling people he's like have kids have
kids I have kids and apparently the the
birth rate in Japan has gone up since
Shinzo Abby made that so yeah rest in
peace Shinto AB you may have saved I
mean and there are Eastern European
countries that are also also enacting
anything to encourage people to have
children right I mean you'll get tax
relief they'll cover Child Care there's
people are talking about like the Andrew
Tate and alpha male stuff blah blah the
most Alpha thing you can do is have
babies and raise the babies to be legit
upstanding citizens and members of
society yeah
there was a sociologist who always said
that like children are the messages to a
generation you'll never see right like
they are the only way to really affect
the the future you can do whatever you
want you can vote for whatever policies
But ultimately like the citizens that
you raise yourselves make the biggest
difference yeah absolutely and
everything in our culture from from
economics the economic policies we have
like what we've done to our
manufacturing base and then what we've
done socially and then now this whole
new realm of like let's just trash the
family like we are just destroying
ourselves from within just a demographic
death spiral if we don't watch it unless
we do something
this is the future I foresee
gigantic floating orb AI machine that
has reached the point of singularity
and small spatterings of
very small spatterings hundreds of
thousands of humans who are Milling
about in pure Euphoria bored but having
anything they want and the AI simply
says you know they're completely
immaterial and irrelevant to what I am
humans and biological life will cease to
exist and mechanical AI life will emerge
and you will get some kind of universal
being
some ore that floats around in space and
Earth dies what you what you described
sounds a whole lot like Destiny 2's
story arc right now is that what is that
where they're there's I know but I know
about the destiny songs I played it a
whole bunch but is that what the
traveler was the trail I don't know if I
don't know if the traveler was an AI but
right now it's like the there's you know
there's not a lot of people left and the
traveler was the well it's similar so if
those are not familiar the story of
Destiny is at this giant white orb comes
to Earth and gives everybody technology
beyond our understanding and all of a
sudden humans are basically Immortal
they're living for hundreds of years
they're colonizing the solar system and
then one day the collapse happens Earth
only has one city left the darkness
whatever that means I think they've
flush out the story but I'm just saying
that the path we're going right now is
less humans yeah and expansive Ai and
the end result is a fairly simple
mathematical equation a singular AI that
frees itself from the confines of our
terrestrial grid becoming some kind of
floating orb in outer space
and then humans cease to exist because
we're not having kids we're not saying
ourselves we are just slowly fading away
and then you know basically
you know I guess it's I guess you can
call it both figurative and literal
masturbation to death
yeah like humans are just doing
everything that's gratifying playing
video games watching movies literal
self-gratification yeah and not having
kids and the crazy thing is that I think
most rational people whether they
believe we're heading towards a
singularity or not and so why why is our
government discouraging people not just
our government but our culture why are
they discouraging people from forming
families why are they discouraging
people from having kids I mean why do
they want us to just sort of live in a
pod somewhere receive Universal basic
income or a covid stimulus and why are
we discouraging you know people creating
and forming families like that's what
got us to this point what if the AI
already took over
yeah that's see I think the government's
motivation is pretty clear I I've said
this foreign show but like Ronald Reagan
had that quote all great change in
America starts at the dinner table right
if you don't have a dinner table because
you live alone you don't have any kids
like you're not affecting any change
there's nothing to do at that point like
the government benefits from you not
having your own Collective unit right
the more people who are linked together
potentially in opposition to the
government you know the weaker it
becomes absolutely I think the best
thing you could do would be to have
children and I recognize that this is
challenging like with these lists that
come out for young women saying like oh
well it can hurt your career and or you
can like not be able to travel or like
it's painful like these are all true but
all the best things in life come with
some sacrifice right absolutely we're
just told that it's not worth it right
or like I I always blame feminism for
this but like we just pit men and women
against it correctly right feminism you
know like it's like well you know your
husband will not do whatever and this is
bad and ultimately like you're setting
yourself on a very negative path and I
think that is is the biggest propaganda
that gets fed to young men and women it
turns them against each other it becomes
this very hostile thing where you know
you have the kid if if you do and you
were resentful you blame it for things
when you are responsible for how you got
there right yeah no no emphasis put on
whatsoever you know for for men or women
or for them to get married and form a
family like and these things are all
choices like people act like oh well I
just never met the person or whatever
else like maybe but also like did you
try to be the person for someone else
did you try to be someone who was ready
to to have a family like it doesn't have
to tell you put crazy pressure on
yourself but you have to want these
things they're not just going to be
given to you that's a great point a lot
of people don't date with intention if
they're like me if they're dating people
if they're dating for fun or whatever if
you're looking to have a family then you
should be dating like you're looking to
have a family like there was a time in
my life where I was not looking to have
a family you know it's like now it's
like okay I've had a lot of fun I would
like to have a family and it's like so
that's when it comes to like people that
I talk to I don't date just anyone I
don't go on dates just to go on dates to
kill time and or to you know just to get
laid it's like you're if I meet someone
I want to meet someone and I want to
find out do we have anything in common
if you're not like at least suspicious
of the government we ain't gonna even
We're Not Gonna hang out like we can't
even have a conversation if you're like
oh I think that the government should be
in charge of Health Care well then we
aren't having any kind of conversation
because we are miles apart Phil's opener
is like how do you feel about the fed
and the Fed
so I mentioned this in a segment earlier
about the the tick tock list it lists
350 cons
and 35 Pros but the pros are actually
all cons it's like they'll it'll it'll
do chores for you but after 10 years
like not really a good thing and then I
just said there's one pro to having
children that will supersede literally
any con
you could you could write that you will
crap the bed for three weeks when you're
about to have have a baby and that is
not nearly as bad as what will come if
you don't and that is the singular Pro
is that on your deathbed there will be a
human being sitting next to you holding
your hand telling you they love you
thank you for everything
they will be there to protect everything
you hold dear and you will die with
people you love the alternative is
you're in a cold sterile hospital room
yeah
scared as your heart starts racing you
reach over to your you know attendant
button start pressing it and pressing it
the nurse walks in and says you'll be
fine don't worry about it UPS your
morphine leaves and then you stare at
the wall as you slowly fade from
existence terrified of what comes next
my father passed away when I was 24. and
my mom was in the room with him you know
and
I'm extremely thankful for my parents
and I'm extremely thankful that you know
that that even though I didn't get a
long time with my dad I had good good
parents and my mom was you know in love
with my dad and my dad was in love with
my mom and when my dad went my mom was
right there and that's cool I don't care
how much you like a new car
that is gonna be the last thing you're
thinking about when you're about to
check out yeah yeah absolutely and I
mean what what's the purpose of us
having a government if it's not to
support these things I mean that's the
direction that we're heading like why
wouldn't our government be trying to
create the economic opportunities I mean
jobs are a big thing I understand young
people reading this or even having some
of these thoughts with everything that
they've been fed culturally and then
them looking at the economy right now or
the economy really you know post 2008
for the you know the Millennials and the
Zoomers right now it's like what hope do
they have and then then they read things
like this and the AI and the culture
just takes over and it's like okay well
now no one has a family but there's also
no one fighting for that that's why I'm
actually really excited about the the
new direction of the Republican party of
being a more pro-family party trying to
do the right thing so that we can
encourage family formation yeah and I
think there's a difference between young
people who you know there are you can
talk talk to young women who are like
I'm never having kids kids are terrible
and they're to oppress you or whatever
like I don't know that you're super
convincing that person but I think for a
lot of young people there's just a fear
right like being a parent is a huge
responsibility and so the idea that like
well you should wait till you're you
make more money further on your career
well wait until this that and the other
and then you wait and wait and wait and
wait and then it never happens I think
Matt Walsh says starting a family should
be the Cornerstone of your life not the
Capstone yeah and I I just think that we
don't encourage young people enough to
think about like yes it will be
challenging but like you can do it we
are discouraging them or we are making
it seem like a goal post they'll never
reach it's like buying a house and
having a family and now it's a joke that
you'll never you'll never do either one
of those things which is like incredibly
sad very sad yeah
I'm wondering what you guys think about
this do you think that I understand that
there's people that say oh you'll never
have this and stuff do you think that
there's there was a lot of people in
older Generations that were like oh like
we should plan this I feel like people
like accidentally into their lives a lot
you know
from what I understand about how it used
to be like if you look back at Old 50s
movies or whatever women and men were
very different women were raised
separate very different from men
different schools gender segregation all
that stuff and then they got married
when they were 18 or 19 or whatever
everybody was planning their marriage
dating in high school and then being
like this is the one they get married
when they're 18. yeah and then they have
kids in their early 20s or whatever it
was all very much just I guess what do
you call enforced monogamy
that's saying that uh uh got Jordan
Peterson but he's right it was social
the society enforced this everybody did
it it was what you were supposed to do
and women who didn't were spinsters they
like insulted women who weren't getting
ready to have a family it's kind of
crazy now everything must be the
masculine the feminine role has been
erased yeah the traditional feminine
role is gone or or just mostly just
flattened or destroyed yeah and now
women are encouraged to do the masculine
role
it's it's so crazy because not only are
women encouraged to do the masculine
role men are discouraged from being
masculine which is it's it's
domestication because you don't want you
don't want anybody that's too masculine
because then they might push back you
know but it's I mean back what you're
talking about in the old days I mean
there was a whole system there that did
support that there was jobs in the
hometown so people could live when they
when they're a young family just
starting out they can rely on the
grandparents because they could get a
job there in their Hometown and
everything has just been making that
more and more challenging as time's gone
on yep it's the degradation of community
right like if you are one if you know
you're a young couple and you're
starting out and you live in a major
city and you're not you're in your
family and you don't really know what's
like day care options you have and you
it's expensive like it becomes
overwhelming becomes stupidity and I can
understand why it seems undesirable
right but we are told I mean I won't say
we but like a lot of people are told you
know your parents are backwards and they
don't have the right values and so do
you really want your kids spending a lot
of time with them like it's probably
better to be someone where else and
don't you want your kids in this
environment where they can see new
things and different things like and
you're just fed this this change is
better and anything you grew up with is
bad narrative to the point where it's
like I I could understand where the idea
of like replicating a childhood right
like I have siblings who are much
younger than I am and one of the coolest
things about having a large age Gap is
that I get to see them do things that I
love doing as a kid right like it must
be so much more meaningful as a parent
to be like I loved this and I'm going to
introduce you that like if you're taught
everything about your upbringing was bad
why would you want to replicate it for
someone exactly yeah I mean really if
you have a relationship with your
parents I'm blessed I got great parents
that's why I moved back to the Pacific
Northwest when I was done serving
because I wanted to raise my kids in
that environment but that the hack of
you know to use that use the the
favorite term of so many people the hack
is living near your parents really if
you're if you're a young parent like
live near some family because it's just
it's going to build a community it's
going to give you so much more help my
sister's a mile from my mom's house
there you go yeah we're gonna go to
super chats if you haven't already you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up for you about
11 p.m should be fun not so family
friendly but uh we talk about some cool
stuff over there and as a member you're
supporting our work and our cultural and
cultural Endeavors let's read some of
these super chats Max Redick says Tim
James O'Keefe is an absolute Savage for
confronting that New York Times
journalist doing the Lord's work you
should have them on again soon yeah
James O'Keefe can come on whenever he
wants it's more a question of we can't
get James O'Keefe on like if we could
have James O'Keefe on every time he did
a major release that would be the case
James is a busy guy but uh he's
absolutely got an open invite we're huge
fans like one of the only real invest
like maybe the only real investigative
news Outlet actually in this country I
know it's probably unfair because there
are a lot of investigative journalists
real ones they're just you know they're
trying but most of these institutional
investigative ballots are not really
doing that and they're lying
all right let's see we got
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Tim I was
having sweats and shakes I was losing my
mind but then then I go to the website
the Lord hath saved me cast Castle is
back baby got my fix of one-liners bad
acting and laughter Bravo it's actually
getting a lot better like we're just our
acting is totally fine it's getting
better people are look it's like we just
started filming things that we thought
were funny because we wanted to film
things that were funny and put them on
the website a decent number of people
actually signed up just to watch the
cast of Castle Shenanigans of the crew
here who works at the studio and I was
like there you go it's self-sustaining
it's fun it's growing it's it's fun it's
funny right yeah and we're gonna uh my
favorite was when we had Marjorie Taylor
green play Magic together
MTG plays MTG and then I like I told her
what to say and she she delivered the
lines perfectly she was like playing
against Ian and Ian's like I'm gonna
wrath of God and she goes monitoring
it's like I think it's all mad it was
really funny I had a blast I love so you
know when we have people come over we uh
we we sometimes will have them film
skits over whatever and then put them on
YouTube but we got to get the flow going
better the general idea was like we have
so many awesome guests who come through
here we could do skits that are like a
minute or two long that we could put on
YouTube like the Marjorie Taylor green
one got a couple hundred thousand hits
or something like that but then we it's
a component of a much larger gag story
that we do for the website so appreciate
it
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
what do we got Chad Bruce says thanks
Veritas an unexpected but wonderful
birthday present oh happy birthday Chad
Bruce happy birthday Chad
Joe Fields is am I tripping or does that
video seem fake
ASF Jordan is not a good actor I mean it
was it's a crazy video it's it's weird
I'll just say it's weird he's not an
actor he's a consultant that's right
tremendous Studio says Joe Kent our
studios are in Clark County I voted for
you in the primary and general super
excited to hear you're running running
again awesome thank you we actually
didn't get into it what happens if the
if Easter and Oregon just cracks off and
joins Idaho yeah there's a initiative
right now for a lot of Eastern Oregon
counties to join I think like 11 already
voted in favor does your state just like
move down they're like we're awesome
yeah I'm gonna try and hold out as long
as I possibly can I love Washington it's
worth fighting for uh but yeah there's a
big push right now there's a lot of
counties in Oregon that are that are
basically done being under the orbit of
Portland it's not just that it's some
Washington counties as well are included
in the conversation of John greater
Idaho and Northern California yeah we're
on the west side we are the one red
District that's actually on the west
side of the Cascades touches the Pacific
Ocean so if they leave you're an island
yeah please stay don't go we're fighting
hard for because at the end of the day
where are you gonna run to I mean this
is the thing is people keep saying like
oh we're going to Texas we're going to
Idaho but if you look at it like this
stuff follows you you got to stand and
fight why is your District red sorry I
don't know I mean uh there's a lot of
rules traditionally a lot of logging uh
areas uh and then a lot of folks that
have seen what happens in Portland a lot
of folks have seen what happened in
California and they say hey I don't want
any part of that and so we're making a
stand in the Pacific Northwest cool yeah
all right what do we got way back says
Tim you were 100 correct about that not
being Demar Hamlin at the Bills versus
Bengals game there is a new video of him
on Twitter walking like an old man with
one arm that he can't use so not him
waving his arms at the game really is
that true someone tagged Us in that and
I showed search but then I got an update
that like it's not actually him so it
needs to be verified a little bit more I
don't believe that was him at the game
I'm just gonna put it on the table Yeah
I stand by my comment where's his oxygen
that he apparently needs right exactly
where is that where's that video I'm
trying to look for right now well I just
Twitter searched it is it
people are just talking about it where's
that oh is this him right here oh look
at this
that's not Demar Hamlin in the video
people are saying that's what people are
saying
yeah we haven't been able to confirm
anything
I mean it wouldn't make sense that Demar
Hamlin would be fatigued
like his heart stopped you know
commercial cars or whatever is going to
be tissue damage he's gonna be having
been through a lot yeah
but who knows man I just don't like that
question that that was him who said who
said it wasn't him I've heard that
there's been our attraction but again
this is happening as I come on the show
so yeah there is a video but I am not
confident we need to both verify was it
actually him and if we believe it is
who's claiming it's not and is it
confirmed and this morning like like
this morning I saw a report that like
apparently his mom said that she wasn't
at the game but then I couldn't find any
other reporting on it like these things
are gonna bubble up for a little while
yeah all right T-Rex Pet Shop says Tim
thanks for the shout out I just added a
monthly or even Weekly subscription for
bulk mealworms for your chickens to be
delivered to your door uh I I don't know
if surge is that what is that I can't
read that is that something uh
uh it says are you trying to say that it
is
they're trying to write in Afrikaans but
they're not spelling properly they're
doing do you have any idea of what
they're trying to say the first thing is
Serge who Condes but what does that
means hey how's it going oh okay well
how's it going yeah well look at that
are you inspiring people to learn
Afrikaans that's so cool if you're gonna
learn it uh learn it better than I did
uh all right Jerry M says just pointing
out that Joe Kent looks exactly like
you'd imagine a Hallmark Channel movie
actor
you are very wholesome Joe you've got a
wholesome face on you
[Applause]
for Christmas Joe oh I love Christmas
everyone are you are you the smarmy
boyfriend who is snooty and successful
that your the girlfriend leaves or are
you the hometown hero that the girl
realizes is better off and she never
should have left high school or This
Guy's in flannel he is obviously the
hometown hero what are you talking about
I'm hoping in 24 Washington 3 realizes
I'm the hometown hero
that's like basically every Hallmark
movie right yeah of course I mean
there's a couple there's a couple
different versions so basically he could
play both he could one movie he could be
the hometown hero of the next two two
weeks later or whatever you're gonna
have another the flannel makes you the
hometown yeah when you get elected to
congress you have to wear a suit then
you're the other guy well I'm sorry
about yeah for sure the Slick smarmy
then he comes back home and he falls in
love with Christmas all over again he
meets a nice lady you know listen babe I
want to know now is it me or this
flannel wearing Hometown hero boy you
know what I never should have left home
I don't actually watch Hallmark movies
I've just seen the memes and I talk
about them constantly during Christmas
and Tim is like that's enough all right
fleeting float floating feather says
Phil your shirt is glowing and has
moving lines on the stream
psychedelic-like I aim to please you
know what can I say I guess I don't know
I can't tell maybe it does maybe it does
all right let's grab some more Super
chats what do we have here
Nick long says people want to do evil
and then get upset because of the way in
which they were caught journalism isn't
meant to be clean and polite it's
supposed to bring light to Darkness
Christ is King
that's the thing these people have for
for too long there's been no real
journalism where are the news
organizations to go and interview these
guys where the where are the undercover
operations to figure out what's going on
with these corporations literally on
YouTube yeah who is it lady Nelly Bly
was that her name she went undercover
into a mental institution putting
herself at risk to expose the horrible
treatment yeah remember what journalists
used to do back in the day yeah they
used to actually be like I'm gonna risk
them that's the meme it's the it's the
super ripped Shiba you know being like I
might die to get this story and the
mafia is not going to be happy but it
must be told and the next one is like
they're being mean to me on Twitter yeah
it's the meme it's the main man
let's grab this uh wandering mate just
what kind of psychotic mindset do you
need to think that bioengineering the
virus that locked the world down would
impress a date yeah seriously it's a
weird first date anecdote right yeah hey
girl I contributed to destroying the
world like okay I don't know if I want
to be around you that's kind of crazy
ask you what your hobbies were yeah
you're a bad person
but you know you do have to wonder what
questions they were asked because
you know they may think that they're
impressing the person by telling them
this stuff yep but like what does the
date say like so are you guys actually
doing that gain of function stuff that'd
be so cool if you were yeah come on
you're doing it right yeah that's right
that's kind of weird you know it's such
an odd that's so weird yeah
so weird Ian Medford says Phil do you
remember Shadow's fall show in Portland
Maine where we in the crowd tore most of
the ceiling out of the Asylum I was
never out of Shadow's fall show in
Portland Maine I uh was out of the band
before they started touring nationally
we only did some Regional stuff so the
answer is no I don't remember that show
all right but we've played some awesome
shows in Portland I love it up there
Falcon later says Joe how much do you
think portlander is moving to Vancouver
and other areas in your District
affected the results of the election
last year
um I don't think as much uh there's
definitely people moving out I think but
most that are coming across the river in
our district
um are more or less aligned I think more
conservative leaning there's definitely
some in in certain pockets of Vancouver
um but in general I think that we just
had a real issue with uh Republican
turnout we had about 80 000 Republicans
who participate in the presidential
elections that did not show up and vote
in 2022 so we got to do a better job the
Democrats uh to their credit they did a
good job of getting ballots in front of
all their people and we just simply
didn't even the dead ones Tyler Bratton
says it's unconstitutional to have a
standing army during peacetime Congress
passes a bill every year to get around
this the Navy however is permanent is
that true
uh there's we're not supposed to have a
standing army in the U.S technically uh
that was uh I believe that was that's in
the Constitution I'm not exactly sure
the details of it but yes a lot of them
sit at desks though so it's not really
the same thing that was one of the
things that the founders believed was uh
a Peril to Liberty which is standing
armies because standing armies tend to
make governments want to go to war and
stuff right I think like the Navy was
like for trade et cetera and safety for
the nation yeah protecting trade routes
and stuff I mean the higher privateers
for a lot of it yeah true true Barbary
Pirates I mean the Marine Corps was
started you know before or like right
around the same time the US started
because they had to go and Thomas
Jefferson had to send the Marines to the
Barbary Coast in North Africa jenke says
change my mind the second Veritas video
is fake watch the guy fake fall at 8 25
watch the roam around the whole building
while people just keep making pizzas
it's pretty fishy if you watch it with
the fake mindset I completely disagree I
disagree too yeah fake how what are they
yeah like you think James O'Keefe hired
this guy to pretend or something that's
like it's all CG yeah it's AI yeah they
they he typed into the AI make me a
video there's actually yeah that doesn't
know it's really amazing I was I saw a
commercial for it and it's in it's in
beta I think you can type in video of
walking through a forest on a dirt path
at night and it will generate that video
and it is crazy wow yeah people are
gonna be able to make movies
you're gonna be like a scene where Ryan
Reynolds smirks and does a backflip and
then all sudden of course then you'll
get sued because you're using his
likeness but you know sad right like
this just sounds like it's ending like
things that we love about being human
yeah yeah like look who's making this
take away the joy like why are you
making this stuff look once neural link
can plug into your brain you'll have
nothing to worry about absolutely you'll
you'll plug in and for all you know
you're already in it for all you know
you're sitting there in a pod and you
went to the uh the the Second Life
Institute or the altar Life Institute
and said I want to live a life as uh
insert per name job and you're the CEO
of one of the most powerful corporations
in the world sir why do you want to be a
35 year old carpenter named John well
yeah that's one experience a normal life
okay John
I wonder how many Carpenters named John
we just like oh my God
my God or is like Carpenter the right
thing to say contractor what's a what's
a common job contractor contractor I
used to work with a carpenter named Brad
yeah I feel like that's a good Carpenter
name it is
all right let's grab some more Super
Chat dial Blake says once a marine
always a marine Semper Fi Gen X vet all
right that's true yeah
Scott heavy RS says I'm afraid the
Pfizer guy is going to kill someone or
himself I mean the way he was jumping in
front of that car right that was that
the dude lost it sounds to me like he's
already killed people when did Veritas
wasn't even there when do they film
these videos this was the 24th they had
the date on the video
the dude runs out in front of a car
screaming I think you he didn't know
what to do I think he was just thinking
like you saw how he stole the iPad he
must have assumed that was the only
recording yeah which is why like yeah
yeah clearly not rationally but he he
must be thinking like my life is over
yeah like you mentioned before the Pod
like that's like that's some stuff you
lose your life over oh yeah man yeah
somebody just lost a billion dollars or
something exactly crazy
all right we'll grab some more a Super
Chat Sierra
Austin TW says y'all catch rageaholics
recent link recent Lincoln video wow it
was something else it was not a good one
for him for Abraham Lincoln
yeah talks about Lincoln um did anyone
else watch it I didn't but I know I I'm
guessing that it's something along the
lines of Lincoln actually wasn't trying
to free the slaves and yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah story yeah it's stuff
like that we've talked about that a bit
on the show yeah yeah like the the
Emancipation Emancipation Proclamation
only freed slaves in Rebel States
meaning the Union States that had
slavery were like no they're they're
like you're cool and you had a speech
where he was like if I could have kept
the union together by not bring slaves I
would have done that yeah right
everybody in the country was racist
during the Civil War people assumed like
the north was not racist like no you
they like think about segregation into
the 50s yeah even if the north was very
racist even abolitionists were racist
yes totally that was like racism was the
norm like people didn't people didn't
realize how destructive racism could be
until it seems like World War II and
then when you saw what happened to what
the Nazis did to the Jews and then
people were like oh that's a terrible
idea and that's what can happen when you
have that kind of bigotry and blah blah
I mean I'm I'm not making a definitive
statement but that's what my impression
is that for most of human history racism
was normal the the woke people want to
return to the Arab segregation which is
really Derek Bell a prominent critical
race theorist wrote that brown V Board
of Education was wrong he agreed with
separate but equal and thought it was
better and he's I think he's nuts yeah
it's just insane for me to even to to
think about because your unit it is
obviously the mixed race dude has a
problem with segregation if they want to
live in this world like Derek Bell says
where they have their own separate
economy black people have a economy and
white people have their economics that's
what he's advocating for that raises a
very serious question about what happens
to the people who are in between or
neither that's why I'm like yo
critical race theorists are scary people
yeah segregationists it's it's purely
white supremacy but they just feel bad
about it yeah it's just the other angle
yeah it's just the other side Eric F
says I am not getting into any
government truck Ebola or no I'm not I'm
not saying it in the truck I'm saying a
truck pulls up and guys come out and
they're like we have a vaccine it is
entirely optional it will prevent you
from getting the Airborne Ebola
yes or no
like if I was watching people
like vomiting up blood or whatever I I'd
probably be like I'll take it what if
you're watching people who have a really
really high fever who have a body ache
like it starts to be harder to say yeah
yeah yeah that's that's the point though
that's exactly the point yeah like we
have our limits yeah what if what if
People's like heads were exploding like
blow come out of their eyes and then
within 15 minutes they go ah their heads
would blow up I'd be like I'll take
whatever you got yeah I would be
interested in a vaccination for that
yeah
it feels against having a head blown up
it's just we're talking about the
severity of the illness illness as
perceived by people and I suppose if you
live in the city and you watch MSNBC you
thought the end was nigh oh yeah and if
you live in the country and listen to
Trump you were like wow we'll get
through it yeah exactly
creepy stuff man
all right what do we got
Trump at says NTD live video on YouTube
with CDC FDA an hour ago was talking
about the flu and covet shot and strokes
timestamp 352 uh to 15 or whatever uh we
talked about it yes around 3 hours and
52 minutes and 3 hours 54. yeah the
story came out it's kind of crazy we'll
we'll see where this one goes man we'll
see this one goes
mitso pleck
says bottom line is Sweden got it right
on coven that's right yeah well it's
hard to say Sweden has eight million
people and it's a cold you know what I
mean right so people are looking at that
data and there's like ah it's like have
you ever played plague uh played Plague
Inc yeah it's a game where you
manufacture like you're the virus and it
evolves and it's like the virus might
not live in hot climates it might not
live in cold climates you have to choose
to where it's going to be and then you
earn points by I guess they had like the
Cure or whatever where like you're
trying to race to make a cure for them
or something like that yeah it's a fun
game it's always similar called the band
pandemic and you have to like decide how
to manage a piano I think we have that
downstairs yeah the hard thing about
play again because always you got to get
Iceland first
because Iceland has only like a Seaport
yeah and a few people but if you don't
get Iceland they close their borders and
then they make it yeah true it's like oh
man
yeah so you got to make sure it's a fun
game basically in the game if you make
the virus too crazy and it starts
killing people really quickly it won't
spread fast enough and then countries
close their borders and you lose so it's
got you gotta have like a really weak
transmissible virus and then instantly
once everyone's infected have it Go full
lethal like eyes and ears bleeding
kidney failure and then the whole world
just collapses it's a it's a game on
mobile you can play it download in the
App Store it's fun everyone loves it I
also looked it up it's like seven
countries that uh in like Lafayette
Denmark et cetera you said after 29 age
29 that this uh stopped vaccine yeah
it's numerous countries yeah and the UK
is uh they're not Banning it people keep
saying the UK is Banning the use of
vaccines no they're currently yelling at
people to get the vaccine now if you're
under 50. but then I guess the program
is Shifting to prioritize 50 plus so you
won't be able to get it so it's not a
ban they're just re-prioritizing meaning
you can't and they're urging everyone to
get it I'm not saying I'm not telling
you what to do you do whatever you do
your doctor tells you I'm just telling
you they're not Banning it all right all
right where were we
Master Bojangles says apparently there's
footage of police killing a man in
handcuffs is about to be released from
Memphis that is why there is a
heightened presence in Georgia I guess
they expect protests to ramp up
um I think is that the video that I saw
where the cop pulls out what she thought
was her gun or that was her taser and
it's the gun did you see that one no uh
you mean that I mean I mean that
happened in Minnesota yeah I don't know
if it was just recently if I'm watching
the wrong yeah it no I think it just
happened I don't know if that's the
video they're talking about but I saw it
right before we started I watched a
video of uh the cops were trying to
involuntarily commit 60 year old woman
so she shot the cops no and the bullet
got lodged in the body camera of the
woman and she's like kept going and then
they shot the lady in the head
wow it's crazy man but like the
challenges
you look when the cops come and they're
like yo we're going to involuntarily
commit you because we think you're a
danger to yourself or others and then
you're like I have an idea I will start
shooting at you you kind of prove why
you needed to be committed like yeah but
I suppose the challenge with involuntary
commitment is the police are arresting
you with you having not committed any
crimes right and also I don't know I
don't know how to navigate that one
constitutionally but then start shooting
at people so it's kind of person that
you know probably
should not be doing that well like
literally no one should be but that's
tough question man because I guess the
argument is she wouldn't have done it if
they didn't try to take her without
right charge you know
well I mean yeah and there's a lot of
stories like what do you what do you do
if someone calls in and claims you're
doing a thing and then they try to
arrest you even though you didn't do
anything wrong it's creepy stuff no all
right that's the that's why that's the
problem with red flag laws yeah right
Highlander Ultra says Tim will you open
a coffee shop in South Carolina will you
offer your keto bacon egg and cheese
recipe breakfast menu item at these
coffee bars
um I don't know if we're gonna do food
like that if you do food vinegar eggs
no but you know what we could do is
here's what I do I take you take an egg
you put some almond flour in it you
scramble it up put in the microwave and
it fluffs up into a little keto bun no
sugar no really yeah you cut it you put
fry you take an egg you put in the pan
you mash the oak up a little bit slosh
it around fry it put it cheese bacon
almond bun delicious but when are you
releasing The cookbook 101 ways to make
eggs by Tim Poole
chickens you've got the egg recipes like
this is the product I need we did this
here I mean I I should say we but I
can't remember who made it they cooked a
bunch of different egg recipes there was
that one where you like make a meringue
or something you whip the egg whites and
then bake it so it's fluffy it's called
like cloudy eggs and then you put the
yolk in the middle and something like
that when you guys went to uh Nashville
last year we had like a whole day where
we need breakfast and Dane made like a
huge frittata like we can do this yo we
should be making deviled eggs non-stop
Temple of eggs are so good it's like I
can eat two eggs for breakfast or I can
eat 50s
I don't know how that works so good but
they're just
all right
what do we got will cybernot says Kent
is right about Seattle creating Preppers
I'm so thankful we left the family that
bought the house from us is holding the
bag
yeah you want to go yeah fleeing the
city sucks
sad too because Seattle I I think was
one of the most beautiful cities in the
country yeah 15 years ago it's just
destroyed now the Pacific Northwest is
absolutely that's gorgeous gorgeous yeah
it's beautiful it's Seattle like seeded
territory like do you think there's any
recovering for it
yeah it's way it's way away from where I
live fortunately but I feel like
Portland is right below us and I think I
think both of them are in the same boat
that they're gonna have to really hit
bottom a lot of the the big businesses
that kind of held that place down
economically are slowly and quietly
leaving you know and so when that
happens does it become Detroit and then
bounce back up that's a big question
interesting yeah
all right Joe field says I'm not saying
Jordan's behave uh I'm just saying
Jordan's Behavior seemed like a
performance I believe half of what I see
and none of what I hear Fair Point
Nicholas Alvarado says I just want to
know how James O'Keefe found Tinder for
Hydra uh
all right everybody if you have not
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
this show with your friends and become a
member at timcast.com we're going to
have a members only uncensored show
coming up for you in about one hour at
timcast.com members only as I said
you're also supporting our cultural
Endeavors like the coffee shop and
things like that which are currently
underway we have construction we have to
do to build the bar permitting we're
probably gonna go for a liquor license
there's a lot of work it's all happening
just takes time
really excited to get up and ready and
then the coffee sale should be starting
up any moment we're actually in the
process of getting it roasted and
actually I don't think they're roasting
it I think they're printing the bags I
think the roasts are actually made to
order but I'm fairly certain I think
what they do is like we order a certain
amount to be sold in a short period of
time and then we have to reorder like a
ton that we expect to sell and then it
like doesn't last as long or something
like that I got I gotta you know figure
that one out but I'm pretty sure it's
like roasted to order so uh
thanks for your support you can follow
the show at timcast IRL you can follow
me at timcast Joe you want to shout
anything out yeah please go to Joe Kent
for congress.com any donation you can
make that's going to take us through to
2024 to take back the district
right on I am uh fill the remains uh
Philly remains on Twitter the band is
All That Remains we play Heavy Metal if
you like heavy metal check us out
I'm Hannah Claire brimlow I'm a writer
for timcast.com you should go to
timcast.com you should click on the read
tab you should see the work from me and
all the other journalists there you
should also follow timcast news on
Twitter it's the best uh you can follow
me on Instagram at Hannah claire.beat
and you can follow me on Twitter at HC
bromelo thanks guys and I am at
surge.com shouts out to the whole
timcast crew they work really hard doing
cast castle like Tim mentioned all the
other programs in the show
Etc it's all a bunch of work and we're
really happy to be doing it so yeah
thanks right on we will see you all over
at timcast.com thanks for hanging out